Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Sag mal Phipps, du kämpfst auch den ganzen Tag im Channel, oder?
Im Channel Chat.
Du bist immer am Start.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich mich darüber beschweren will oder so, aber es fällt schon auf.
Wine Sirius Max.
Chat, noch irgendjemand von heute morgen den Browser-Tab offen gehabt und sich jetzt gewundert, warum auf einmal der Max wieder schwätzt im Hintergrund?
Dafür bist du während dem Streaming aktiv? Ja.
View-Time, wichtig. Einfach im Hintergrund laufen lassen, wobei ich weiß nicht, ob View-Time irgendwie Twitch richtig ist. Richtig ist.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ich muss mich mehr hydraten, Leute.
Hydrated stayen muss ich.
Was ist denn die deutsche Variante? Hydriert? Was heißt denn das? Hydriert? Sagt auch kein Mensch. Bewässert? Befeuchtet?
Was ist die deutsche Variante?
Das erinnert mich immer wieder an meinen Englisch-Lehrer, der auf Deutsch anstatt Subscription hat er gesagt, subscribieren.
Das war eines der wirklich misshandelsten Wörter, die ich je gehört habe. Subscribieren, Alter.
Ich weiß nicht, dem ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht das deutsche Wort dazu eingefallen.
Aber gut, der war auch ein Jahr vor Rente und ist dann gleich wieder abgehauen danach. Der hat uns ein Jahr ertragen müssen und danach war er weg für immer. Benetzen.
Ich muss mal kurz meinen Streamchat refreshen auf der anderen Seite. Die Chatnachrichten kommen ultra verzögert an gerade. Ich muss das mal kurz selbst testen. Achtung.
Keck. Ja doch, jetzt kommt es gleichzeitig. Du kannst nur subtrahieren. Ja deine CPU kann auch nicht mal das. Deine CPU kann addieren und subtrahiert damit.
Und noch schlimmer, die multipliziert sogar damit und definiert dadurch. Die kann eigentlich nur plus rechnen. Aber mit Overflow, das ist der Trick dabei.
5-Sec-Delay, ich hatte 20-30 Sekunden Unterschied. Hier die letzte Nachricht von Fips, die kam, weiß nicht ob man hier irgendwie die Message, kann ich das hier einschalten?
FFZ Control Center, Timestamps oder so. Ich muss mal das dumme E-Mode weg machen, der Bayer. Timestamps. Timestamps. Wie macht man Timestamps an? Ich schwaße es nicht.
Timestamps. Ja, hier 18.37 Uhr kam die Message und drüben kam die Message 18.39 Uhr. Nee. 18.37 Uhr, also war eine Minute zwischen den Messages Unterschied.
Ne, 17.37 Uhr und da drüben kam sie angeblich auch um 17.37 Uhr. Hä? Das ergibt keinen Sinn, das kam eindeutig später. Man weiß es nicht. Aber mache ich das mal wieder aus, das irritiert hier.
Ich kann den Chat? Ne, ich lasse das so oder? Eins größer können wir machen, da könnt ihr es vielleicht einfacher lesen. So, Timestamps füllen die Messages aus. So, also, nachdem wir uns jetzt hier mit den Randerscheinungen und, Alter, der Max Power ging heute Morgen ab, ne, auseinandergesetzt haben, ich zeige euch mal kurz, was wir gestern gemacht haben und dann wo wir heute dran weiter basteln.
Ja, hast du das Remake? Hast du das Alarmstufe Rot und Einser Remake oder hast du irgendwas anderes? Es gibt ja genug, die man mittlerweile mit Fan-Patches sogar in 16.9, 4K, sonst was spielt. Alarmstufe Rot gibt es einen 4K-Patch. Oder zumindest in 16.9 High-Res-Patch. Das ist ziemlich nice.
Man weiß es. Ja, mal zur Erinnerung, um was es eigentlich geht. Ich habe mir bei Amazon ein Dymo Label Writer 450 gekauft. Noch ohne DRM, so ein Teil hier.
Und das Problem damit ist, soll ich euch mal die offizielle Windows-Software zeigen? Ich zeige euch mal, wie painst-champig diese Windows-Software ist. Wobei, so schlimm ist die eigentlich gar nicht.
Aber ich will keine, nee, ich zeige, nee doch, nee, die ist eklig, die braucht Admin-Rechte zum installieren, was auch immer. Die zeige ich euch nicht. Ich zeige euch Screenshots davon, ich installiere die nicht. Die sieht schon etwas deplatziert. Hier sieht man ein Video davon. Die sieht schon etwas deplatziert aus, diese Software. So als hätten die, keine Ahnung, war auch immer mit einem Microsoft-Account, keine Ahnung.
Also, die sieht schon ziemlich painst-champig aus. So, aber so viele Features will ich nicht haben. Die Sache ist die, guck mal, die können auch Barcodes und QR-Codes inserten. Kann ich auch, kein Ding.
Nee, die kann auch nicht viel mehr, als das, was ich gebaut habe. Keg. Die Musik ist ein bisschen laut. Immer noch. Mach mal eins weiter und mal gucken. Ja, das ist okay.
Ähm, ja. Und das Problem an diesem Label-Drucker ist, dass die neueren Versionen von Dymo, das ist jetzt unabhängig von dem Drucker, die haben DRM in ihrem Etiketten drinnen.
Nämlich, die neueren Drucker von Dymo fressen nur Original-Etiketten, weil die irgendeinen Kopierschutz in Form von einem RFID-Chip im Band drinnen haben. Was auch immer sich die dabei gedacht haben, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich hab zum Glück noch einen Drucker, der hat keinen DRM. Aber eine Sache, die mich halt daran stört, ist, du kannst das Ding halt nicht gescheit über das Netzwerk bedienen.
Die iOS-App ist mega beschissen. Guckt euch das mal an. Das ist legit die schlecht bewertetste iOS-App, die ich je gesehen hab.
Also das musste er erst mal schaffen. 1,3 Sterne. Und die Bewertungen sind nun wirklich absoluter Bodensatz, ist die App.
Ja. Android ist auch nicht viel besser.
Die haben sich's redlich verdient. 1,8 Sterne und beim anderen 1,3 Sterne. Also die, die Mobile-App ist Müll. Zumal du die Mobile-App gar nicht so einfach verwenden kannst.
So. Und was ich mir jetzt gedacht hab, ist folgendes. Ich will weder den Treiber installieren, noch die App.
Brother Label Drucker. Sag mal ein. Sag mal ein. Brother Label QL700. 152 Euro. Ok, das ist ungefähr kleiner als das, was ich mir gedacht hab.
Brother Label Drucker. Sag mal ein. Sag mal ein. Brother Label QL700. 152 Euro. Ok, das ist ungefähr gleiche Preisklasse.
Sieht ähnlich aus. Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen QL und DT? Schauen wir mal kurz. Business-Drucker, Mobil-Drucker, Etikettendrucker, Industrie-Etiketten.
Was muss ich denn da jetzt suchen? Farbetikettendrucker, Desktop-Etikettendrucker. Zu was? QL. Thermo-Direct.
Na ja. Haben die ordentliche Linux-Driver? GitHub. Schauen wir mal. Python gibt es. Eine Python-Library.
Python-Package. Aha. Hat das ein Web-Interface? Guck mal, die haben ein Web-Interface gebaut.
Ja. So kann man das auch machen. Find ich tatsächlich ganz gute Idee.
Letztendlich funktioniert das Frontend, was ich baue, aber für mehr oder weniger alle Drucker dieser Art. Solange es Linux-Driver gibt.
Haben die ordentliche Linux-Driver? Krupps.
Anscheinend. Der Stefan blockt es. Okay, nice. Nice, wenn der Stefan das blockt.
Okay, wahrscheinlich kein großer Akt. Na gut. Letztendlich ist es auch egal. Das funktioniert mit allen solchen Druckern.
Bloodsnake. Danke für den Sub. Hab ich gar nicht gesehen. Nicht geguckt. So, zumindest den Drucker haben wir ausprobiert letztens im Stream.
Haben gecheckt, wie man den unter Linux installiert. Das sah dann so aus. Ja. Guckt. So sah das dann aus.
Haben wir gedruckt auf einem sehr aufgeräumten Basteltisch. Benutzst du eine US-Tastatur? Nee. Da. Da hat es gedruckt.
Texte einfügen ist noch nicht ready. Aber gleich. So, und was wir gestern gemacht haben ist folgendes.
Wir haben einen Web-Editor gebaut für Etiketten. Weil ich schon immer mal ein bisschen Grafikzeuge in JavaScript machen wollte.
Ja, guck. Da kannst du zum Beispiel QR-Codes inserten. In dein Etikett. Oder Material-Design-Icons inserten in dein Etikett.
Ich versuche automatisch zu tracken und droppen. Lul.
Und heute machen wir noch Text. Achso. Und das Wichtigste habe ich ja ganz vergessen euch zu zeigen. KeckW, FFZ. Und man kann Bilder Copy-Pasten.
Copy-Image. Bam. Was macht der Kreis? Der ist da. Der ist da, weil das das Test-Shape ist, mit dem ich getestet habe, wie die Library so grob funktioniert um was zu malen.
Der hat keinen Sinn, dass der Kreis da ist. Wir bräuchten im Hintergrund eigentlich noch was, was anzeigt, wie groß das Etikett, was ausgewählt wurde, wirklich ist.
Eigentlich bräuchten wir hier noch irgendeinen Dropdown.
Oh, das Auf- und Schließen geht nicht, Leute. Lul. Warum ist das Auf- und Schließen kaputt?
Irgendwas haben wir kaputt gemacht, ja. Keck.
Das Auf- und Schließen geht nicht mehr.
Ja, eigentlich müssen wir hier oben noch irgendwie ein Selection machen, welche Label.
Wobei, das können wir eigentlich hier machen. Da machen wir hier so ein Menü mit irgendeinem Settings-Icon.
Ist die Fläche nicht eins zu eins? Nee, aktuell ist die Fläche so groß wie mein Monitor.
Eins zu eins können wir aber auch schlecht machen, weil die Labels sind zum Beispiel 86 x 89 Millimeter.
Das wäre quasi so. Das ist ein bisschen klein.
Aber was wir machen können, ist was, was quasi die gleiche Aspect Ratio hat, ungefähr, wie das Label.
Aber halt auf die Größe vom Bildschirm. Und dann mache ich hier, deshalb habe ich mir zumindest gedacht,
da machen wir hier so ein Get-Wrecked-Tangle, ein Rechteck hin, wo man sieht, wo das anfängt und wo das aufhört.
Aber heute müssen wir uns erstmal darum kümmern.
Guck mal, wie viele QR-Codes ich hier eingefügt habe.
Erstmal darum kümmern, dass wir noch ein bisschen mehr malen können.
Vor allem, dass wir ordentlich Text einfügen können. Aktuell können wir keinen Text einfügen.
Wir können bloß QR-Codes einfügen, was ziemlich sinnlos ist.
Ja, also Text einfügen müssen wir auf jeden Fall machen.
Und wir müssen das auch ein bisschen modularisieren, also das hier muss in eine eigene Component,
dass ich das hier als Menü verwenden kann und nicht quasi ein Menü brauche pro Button und sowas. Das ist eklig.
Ach ja, und das eine Sache, das machen wir zuerst.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wie wir das hier gemacht haben. Insert, QR-Code, Insert, Show Icon Browser.
Warum geht denn das denn auf und zu?
Show Icon Browser.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich da mache, aber...
Normalerweise sollte... Ah, ich heide das nicht mehr. Moment.
Icon Browser, Class, Hidden, wenn nicht Icon Browser geschaut werden soll.
So, und ihr stellt fest, es ist laggy. Es ist richtig laggy.
Guckt mal, ich zeige euch das mal kurz, wann ich klicke. Habt ihr den Klick gehört?
Also sprich, wenn ich klicke, geht es zu, geht es schnell, aber wenn ich klicke zum Aufmachen, das laggt eine Sekunde.
Und das liegt daran, weil der 6.800 Icons oder so hier reinrendert. Das ist ein bisschen viel.
So, minimal, minimal viel. Aber eine Sache haben wir schon relativ gut gemacht, gestern.
Das hier sind SVGs, also sprich, das kannst du skalieren, wie du willst.
Und es bleibt immer...
Ähnlich, ähnlich groß. Sagt man, wie kriege ich denn den Rand weg? Ihr habt doch, ihr habt doch da sicherlich Plan von.
Insert Icon.
Legt das, legt das am Viewport? Wie kriege ich den Rand hier drum herum weg? Ist das der Viewport bei einem SVG?
Hat es Welt, kein Virtual Scrolling. Als Zusatzpaket schon, ja, das werden wir wahrscheinlich auch verwenden.
Ist das hier, was ist denn, wenn ich das auf 0-0 stelle, ist dann der Rand weg?
Nee, dann wird es gar nicht angezeigt, okay.
Ähm, ach, das liegt hier, Breite Höhe daran, legt das, glaube ich.
Das ist ein bisschen davon abhängig.
Ja, das liegt an der Breite Höhe, die ich hier, also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, 200 mache, dann ist wahrscheinlich, weil er das skaliert...
Ja, gut, der muss das immer skalieren. Ach, was weiß ich, ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal auf 100, 100.
Zumindest, das ist das erste, was wir machen müssen. Und ich glaube, eine Sache machen wir vorher noch, weil ich glaube, das ist ziemlich einfach.
Die Sache ist nämlich, der Drucker, der kann ja nur schwarz-weiß. Und wenn ich Bilder einfüge, die sind in Farbe.
Das sieht vielleicht cooler aus, entspricht aber nicht so wirklich der Repräsentation, so wie das dann im Etikett aussieht.
Das heißt, wenn ich das Bild einfüge, mache ich noch irgendeinen Cray-Scale-Filter drüber.
Ich glaube, das ist ziemlich einfach, das habe ich nämlich schon auf den ihrer Seite gesehen.
Guck mal, wo füge ich denn das Image ein? Da.
Insert QR-Code, nee. Handle-Paste, da füge ich das Image ein.
From-Url-Image, so, dass wir sowas machen können wie Image-Cray-Scale oder sowas.
Honva-Cray-Scale. Das muss man auch denen mal wirklich lassen.
Die haben ziemlich nice Dokus, also, die verlassen sich nicht darauf, dass ihr Code sich selbst dokumentiert.
Es ist richtig gut, du findest dir für fast alles was.
So, und man muss einfach sagen, Filter-Cray-Scale und das war's.
Also, das heißt, von der Idee her, wenn ich das jetzt richtig mache, sage ich ihm, Image-Cache-Image-Filter-Cray-Scale.
So, und das sollte jetzt das einzige sein, was ich machen muss.
Wenn ich jetzt CACW-Copy-Paste, ist es schwarz-weiß.
Oh, das ist gar nichts mehr.
Oder ich hab's kaputt gemacht.
Hä? Hab ich das Image dann richtig kopiert?
Ah, ich hab das Image dann richtig kopiert.
Jetzt ist es grau, okay.
Guck, jetzt konvertiert er das in ein schwarz-weißes CACW.
Was auch viel besser ist.
Das entspricht viel eher dem, wie man das beim Drucker dann auch am Ende sieht.
Black and white CACW.
So, gut.
Was hab ich gesagt? Ach so, das Gelegge machen wir als nächstes, dass das hier so laggy ist.
So, dann hab ich was gefunden auf Shithub, nämlich githubs-welt-virtual-list.
Macht das File-Browser-Icon schon etwas?
Das File-Browser-Icon fügt einen QR-Code ein, das ist Schwachsinn.
Nee, das macht noch nichts. Also, du brauchst den File-Browser auch nur am Rande, weil du kannst ja Copy-Paste-Images machen.
Aber File-Browser mach ich dann in Pop-Up oder so, wo du Datei öffnen, uploaden machen kannst.
Also nicht uploaden, sondern Browser öffnen machen kannst. Das sollte relativ easy werden.
Jetzt kümmern wir uns erstmal darum, dass das hier nicht mehr so laggy ist.
Weil das ist ja nicht wirklich bedienbar.
So, was ich da gefunden hab, ist sowas hier. Guck mal. Svelte-Virtual-List.
Und von der Idee her ist das relativ easy.
Du installierst das, importierst das, legst eine Liste an und dann sagst du ihm, wie er die Items rendern soll.
Und dann checkt er, welches Item ist sichtbar hier im Scroll Viewport und welches nicht.
Und er lädt das dann nur rein, wenn es sichtbar ist. Das sollte es deutlich schneller machen.
Aber ist das Cray-Scale nicht falsch, weil der Drucker keine Graustufen kann?
Doch, der Drucker kann, glaube ich, Graustufen.
QR-Code-Scan. Warum? Ich will kein QR-Code-Scan, ich will QR-Code-Generieren.
Das funktioniert jetzt schon, den QR-Code-Generieren.
Hier, guck mal. Natürlich auch ohne, nur mit Beispieltext.
Scannen, warum willst du QR-Code-Scan?
Also das mit Cray-Scale kann der Drucker, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, weil es sah zumindest so aus.
Guckt euch mal die Beispiele an, die ich hier ausgedruckt habe.
Naja.
So, das habe ich ausgedruckt. Guck, das sieht schon nach Cray-Scale aus, das grüne hier vom Frosch.
Ich meine, der trickst natürlich ein bisschen und lässt weiß vom Etikett und sowas.
Also das sieht schon Cray-Scale aus.
Aber nur so nach 3-4 unterschiedlichen Stufen, ja wahrscheinlich, aber was soll ich machen?
Es muss erstmal so bleiben.
Es sieht auf jeden Fall realistischer aus als in Farbe.
So, aber jetzt müssen wir erstmal machen, dass es nicht mehr so leckt.
Also installieren wir jetzt virtualist. NPM install.
Leute, kann man das einfach so hinschreiben oder muss ich das quoteen, wenn da Ads und sonstige Sachen davor sind?
Ich quote das mal lieber.
Was? Hab ich das gerade richtig gesehen? Bild Android 64?
Habt ihr das auch gerade gelesen, dass da was von Android 64 stand?
Ich will es gar nicht genau wissen. Hauptsache es funktioniert, es ist mir egal, ob es für Android ist.
Ja, aber Skript ist ja nicht plattformspezifisch auf der Ebene.
So, virtualist und jetzt fügen wir hier eine Liste ein.
Ach, du meinst das Icon QR-Code-Scan.
Warte mal, können wir uns ja mal vergleichen.
Hier Material-Icons. QR-Code.
Also das haben wir und du würdest das verwenden?
Hm, ich weiß nicht. Wir scannen ja nicht.
Wahrscheinlich ist am besten das hier QR-Code plus, weil wir fügen den QR-Code hinzu.
Das können wir übrigens an der Stelle auch mal machen. Aktuell habe ich das ja noch hier embedded, die Icons.
Aber wir haben ja eine MDI-Library drinne.
Also eigentlich kann ich an der Stelle sagen,
eigentlich kann ich an der Stelle sagen, so das ist QR-Code,
kann ich sagen Icons QR-Code.
Ich weiß nicht. Nee. Oder auch nicht.
Okay. Warum nicht?
Das mache ich doch hier auch so. Icons, Icon.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht mal kurz anzeigen lassen. Icons.
Morgen KS.
Das war vielleicht keine so gute Idee. Icons hier rein zu hauen.
Ja, Lock. Wir müssen das unbedingt ein bisschen modularisieren, das ist zu viel.
Was?
Modular. Ach nee.
Das ist, das ist wirklich sehr abartig gemacht, wie ich das ja hier.
MDI.
Wo sind dann, wo sind dann die QR-Codes Leute hier? QR, QR.
Wo ist es denn? Kann man da nichts nicht geschaffen? Alter 6000 der Icons, man.
MDI QR-Code vielleicht, ja. Tatsächlich, wahrscheinlich.
Kannst du das Icon nicht als Objekt in der Hand nehmen?
Tatsächlich, wahrscheinlich. Kannst du das Icon nicht als Objekt importieren? Doch.
Für die Verwendung hier unten wäre das tatsächlich sinnvoller.
Aber für das, was ich hier mache, nämlich 6000 Icons on the fly generieren, kann ich sie nicht einzeln importieren.
Also ich könnte quasi die Icons, die ich brauche in irgendeine Icon-Component rappen oder so.
Das wäre vielleicht MDI QR-Code.
No.
Ähm, wie suche ich denn da drinnen jetzt gescheiter?
Weißt du was? Ich mach jetzt, ich mach jetzt die Noob-Variante.
Boah. Boah. So.
Oder Log. Da sind wir doch. Also QR-Code.
QR? QR?
Hier. MDI QR-Code. Was ist denn das für eine wirre Schreibweise?
MDI QR-Code.
What the f... Bin ich jetzt zu... Ach so.
Moment. Das ist nicht Console-Log, Leute. Ich bin heute nicht richtig bei der Sache.
Ja, das sieht gut aus. Also MDI QR-Code. Das müsste meine extra Icon-Component rappen oder so.
Das ist dann schöner. Aber dafür tut es jetzt erstmal.
Da haben wir es wieder. QR-Code und das andere ist QR-Code Scan.
Leute, was findet ihr besser? Das da oder das da? Oder QR-Code Plus haben wir auch noch zu bieten.
Ich bin ja für das normale QR-Code, ehrlich gesagt. Oder das mit dem Plus. Plus, weil wir adden ja. Weil wir adden ja.
Da ist was mit dem Plus vielleicht gar nicht verkehrt.
Weißt was? Ich ersetz den Kram hier auch gerade nochmal.
Ach, scheiß drauf. Das machen wir eh als Icon-Component später. Das ist ja abartig so. Das kann man überhaupt nicht richtig verwenden.
Okay. Also, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? Was ist denn jetzt die eigentliche Geschichte, die ich machen wollte?
Das ist nicht so leckt. Guckt euch das mal an. Das ist echt nicht normal.
Dann gehen wir an die Stelle, wo ich die Icons rendere. Hier render ich die Icons.
Von der Idee her müsste das so aussehen. Items filtert Icons.
Item gleich, wie möchte ich das? Es heißt Icon. Ist schon nicht verkehrt. So, und anstatt ein Each zu machen, rendern wir jetzt mal das Diff da rein.
Und mal gucken, wie das dann ausschaut, ob das funktioniert.
Nö. Warum nicht? Wo ist das Problem? Aber es geht schnell auf.
Aus welchen Gründen funktioniert das jetzt nicht? Wie wäre es, dass man die Label speichern kann? Ja, ja, das muss ich auf jeden Fall noch machen.
Warum lädt er nicht zumindest das Icon jetzt? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Moment. Icon. Der macht gar nichts hier, oder? Sekunde Leute.
Der macht gar nichts? Warum nicht? Warum funktioniert der Krempel nicht?
Show Icon. So machen wir das standardmäßig mal true, dass ich das nicht immer wieder einplanten muss. Warum macht der hier nichts? Filtert Icons.
Filtert Icons sollte doch eigentlich ein Array sein. Hä? Wait a minute. Warum geht das jetzt? Hä? Ah, weil ich keine Breite habe.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Das ergibt keinen Sinn. Das ist in irgendeinem Grid. Moment. Wartet mal. Nee, nee. Das, das, das, ähm. Wartet mal. Das, das, das, das ergibt so keinen Sinn.
So. Okay. Alla ja, schon besser. Ja, ja. Das war in irgendeinem Grid, was jetzt mit. Nee, nee. Das kann so nicht funktionieren. Okay. Also. Guckt mal. Es laggt null. Schaut mal hier. Bam, bam. Ups. Falscher Knopf. Ja. Ihr hört es ja im Hintergrund klicken. Also das geht wirklich instant auf und zu.
Ja. Nice. Doch das sind alle Elemente. Das sind alle Elemente.
Jetzt geht das Scrollen da drin nicht mehr, Leute. Doch, jetzt. Guck mal. Wenn ich Bild hoch, Bild runter scrolle. Ich habe volle Pulle. Wenn ich habe Scrollen. Also das ist schon einiges, was da drinne ist.
So. Jetzt würden wir natürlich noch schauen, dass das ordentlich verteilt wird, weil so sieht das ja ziemlich beschissen aus. Also. Icon Name kommt schon immer weg. Das brauchen wir nicht. Das brauchen wir dann zum Durchsuchen. Also. Twitter zum Beispiel. Guck mal. Das Filtern ist jetzt auch viel schneller. Seht ihr das? Twitter. Zack. Ist jetzt viel, viel zackiger jetzt alles. Jetzt müssen wir das natürlich bloß noch als. Äh. Grid wieder machen. Allerdings als Grid pro Zeile. Glaub ich. Am simpel. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja
Was hat er denn für schmerzen?
Wenn ich da jetzt ein diff drum mache wo ist denn das problem?
Ah keine höhe ok.
Aber selbst wenn ich selbst wenn ich da ok aber selbst wenn ich da jetzt ein diff rum
mache und sag flex dann funktioniert das ja nicht weil der macht ja ein list item quasi
pro oder ein diff der muss ja scrollen also ohne scrollen wird das nicht funktionieren
svelte hier svelte virtual list row
das wird das das funktioniert nicht
komm mal hier virtual list row virtual list container style padding da kann ich überhaupt
nix dran machen
gibt es sowas svelte virtual grid
x ne infinite meinst du das was nein reddit gehste weg
ich weiß nicht ob uns das was bringt weil ich will ich will ja kein infinite scroll
haben
ja das hier ist infinite scroll das ist abartig das will ich nicht ich weiß ja genau wie
viele items das sind ich will das nicht dynamisch nachladen bis bis zum geht nicht mehr das
darf von Anfang an soll das soll das richtig voll die größe also ich habe eine idee wie
wir das machen also in flexbox fällt mir als nächstes gescheites ein und ganz ehrlich
ich glaube auch dass es mit flexbox nicht gescheit geht weil der das scrollen ja braucht
dass der überhaupt erkennt
kann ich hier disable disable scroll machen
dass er überhaupt erkennt wann was in view ist und wo nicht wir können mal bei denen
auf der seite kurz schauen ob wir style custom styles irgendwie machen können oder so item
halt start end ne das kann man nicht sonderlich gut style
wie ich kann auch nicht mal wenn ich kann auch nicht mal meine
meine scrollbar auspländen na das ist na das ist aber fail ich will meine scrollbar auspländen
disable scrollbar will ich machen
naja das schauen wir uns dann gleich an also ich glaube aber dass ich einfach anstatt
anstatt dass wir hier was außen rum machen müsste doch von der idee her nur mal so ich
müsste doch eigentlich anstatt ist so dass noch mal moment ne das funk jetzt jetzt weiß
ich warum das scheiß nicht funktioniert ich habe hier nur ein item guckt mal leute ich
habe nur ein item pro durchlauf und das ist natürlich mist ein item pro durchlauf
vielleicht kann ich doch in den crit packen
ne dann rennt er da nix mehr wenn ichs in den crit packe
noch mal die höhe vielleicht machen ne das änderts das änderts nicht ich muss ich muss
das irgendwie segmentieren also ich muss jetzt quasi sagen also nur von der idee keine ahnung
wie das funktioniert irgendwie so viel chunk chunker ein großer chunker genau ein chunk
so inszener häppchen will ich das haben so in der richtung müsste ich das machen und
dann könnte ich das rendern
aber wie macht man denn array chunk in javascript ist sowas eingebaut schon array chunk chunked
array genau
stack overflow split array into chunks auf gehts ne ne ich will ein neues array haben
was das macht
gibts da was eingebautes mittlerweile vielleicht
alter what the hell das ist ja richtig massive five hand zeug moment stack overflow antwort
wir copy paste und stack overflow heute wieder das da na gut
wisst ihr was wir sind wir sind äußerst stack overflow driven
chunk sehr schön also probier mal das mal aus ob das jetzt funktioniert also items
packen in 10er blocks so und jetzt noch mal ne schleife drum github copilot das müsste
man echt ausprobieren wahrscheinlich hätte github copilot auch für mich gemacht ja das
ist richtig
so und jetzt kriegen wir hier allerdings ist das nicht ikon sondern ja ikons aber ikons
ist schon ist schon besetzt und filtert ikons ist auch schon besetzt dann heißt es jetzt
einfach chunk ich weiß nicht wie es anders sein soll so sind da jetzt sind da jetzt alle
items drinne zeig mal kurz wo ist das problem jaja gehen wir fort hier
mal kurz break drunter warum warum macht er das jetzt nicht untereinander
klasse keine ahnung margin 5 ahja ok also 10 stück 10 stück pro zeile das ergibt doch
sinn das das das passt doch also nochmal wo war mal hier stehen geblieben ihr ikons ergibt
das sinn was ich mache ietsch und da jetzt eine schleife drum funsta funst das moment
moment würde das so funktionieren ietsch so und da drinne das da jetzt mal für jedes
ikon im chunk so nee moment und da jetzt noch ein grid drum oder dann müsste doch funktionieren
ich bin ich bin verwirrt und da jetzt ein grid drum und dann gehts oder oder nicht chat
beim easy alles klar mal gucken ob das jetzt irgendwie skaliert oder so ich meine es macht
ich meine es macht space dazwischen es gibt schlimmeres das ist bestimmt best practice
ja garantiert ist das best practice was ich hier mache ich mache ja prinzipiell nur best
practice also was solls denn anderes sein außer best practice das kann ich guckt mal
seht ihr wie schnell das jetzt auf und zu geht richtig prog ja huge geschwindigkeit
massive speed alter kann das vielleicht was ist denn wenn ich hier die höhe und die
breite rausnehme was macht dann dann boah eskaliert leute seht ihr das wtf ah aber
hier ist er hier ist er hier ist er nicht schlau genug hier ist er nicht schlau genug
das nachzuladen seht ihr das hier ist er nicht schlau genug das da nachzuladen aber
ich glaube damit kann ich erstmal leben nee immer 10 pro zeile passt doch eigentlich
ist doch ok tatsächlich funst wie kriege ich denn diese hässliche scrollbar hier nebenweg
ich fürchte gar nicht ich glaube diese scrollbar muss sein sonst funktioniert wahrscheinlich
die virtual list component nicht richtig also ich habe jetzt die disable scrollbar class
kann man hier nicht drauf machen das mag er ja nicht boah und ks was jetzt moment das
da vielleicht bisschen verkehrt so versuch mal mit css die class von der component zu
überschreiben mit der scrollbar wenn ich sage hin dann kann ich nicht scrollen das
ist natürlich doof ich will ich will ja scrollen so ich glaube wir müssen es noch mal kurz
verraten wir brauchen noch einen repper und disables der funktioniert nicht wenn ich
die scrollbar disable guckt euch das mal an der sprocken rip warum weil das flex flex
ist weird flex ist das weird flex wartet mal nee moment ok aus irgendwelchen gründen funktioniert
jetzt alles klar ich musste ich musste es neu laden aber jetzt geht das scrollen nicht
mehr jetzt jetzt geht jetzt geht das scrollen hier drin nicht mehr und es ist auch mega
langsam was ist denn da los es leckt wieder wie sau ich check ich check die javascript
geschichte net das ist mir zu six hat alter wo ist denn das problem wenn da noch ein diff
drum herum ist warum ist das ein problem warum wird das langsam wie sau wenn da noch ein
extra diff drum ist mein who cares ob da ein diff drum ist oder nicht check ich net aber
wenn ich virtual list so mache dann geht's alles klar nicht nicht dass ich es in irgendeiner
Art und Weise verstehen würde aber ok so also was soll ich überschreiben die klasse von
so moment was ist denn hier die scrollbar das da oder ja das da also kann ich class
monka es die klasse was ist denn das das kann ich auch im leben überschreiben es ist 1.7.d
hs go was ist denn das schon wieder für ein schwachsinn aber ich müsste das doch auf
das element selekten können oder kann ich nicht kann ich nicht sowas machen
kann ich nicht sowas machen für das element das juckt es nicht
er kehrt nicht dafür keine ahnung ich habe kein blastenschimmer ich glaube wir können
jetzt erstmal mit scrollbar leben ich finde es zwar nicht das ist auf jeden fall nicht
aber wie sagt der weißheitsletzter schluss hier aber besser als nix vielleicht bauen
wir das einfach selbst jetzt jetzt geht's erstmal weil es schön zackig ist der component
eine id geben das geht nicht oder keck weh ne man kann components keine ids geben man
kann die rappen in einem diff und dann eine id geben aber der witz ist ja wenn ichs in
einem diff rappe dann gehts nicht mehr ich hab keine ahnung warum vielleicht liegt das
moment class w12 h12 vielleicht liegt daran das keine höhe und breite hat kann er sein
und es ist mega langsam dann auch also das das check ich nicht das das ist java script
was daran liegen kann vielleicht macht diese komische virtualist component irgendwas merkt
wirkliches ja keine ahnung weil ich mein wo ist das problem
ah ok es war zu klein das das funs doch kann ich sowas wie full sagen aha full nice jetzt
steckt es da im boden leute es steckt im boden so aber wie krieg ich denn jetzt kann ich
es da sagen disable oder scroll scroll ne wie hab ich den kram genannt disable scrollbar
nö ich kann kein scrollbar scroll oder overflow overflow hinten geht das wenigstens nö moment
warum hat overflow hinten einfluss darauf wie das what alter ich blick ich blick nicht
mehr durch java script mann das ist das ist zu high iq für mich zu also wirklich viel
viel zu hoher intelligenzquotient der dafür notwendig ist kann man diese diff rappen hab
ich ja gemacht so aber disable scrollbar bringt an der stelle schonmal nix leute ich hab keine
ahnung wir lassen das jetzt so und irgendwann machen wir selbst wenn mir was besseres eingefallen
ist aber das einfügen und so das geht wenigstens alles noch ok aber die suche ist jetzt auch
schön schnell nice inline wie inline was inline wo ich hab keine ahnung was das bedeuten
soll kann man die virtual list nicht inline im diff rappen ich hab keine ahnung genau
das scroll ist auf dem auf dem diff von der liste das hab ich vorhin versucht zu überschreiben
aber hab ich nicht auf die reihe bekommen enrixel test hat funktioniert aber ganz ehrlich
das ist kleinigkeiten kram das krieg ich immer noch hin jetzt müssen wir uns erstmal ein
bisschen essenzielleren features kümmern dass wir das überhaupt sinnvoll sinnvoll
verwenden können also wie wärs mit text einfügen text einfügen ist glaube ich somit das wichtigste
was man noch braucht dazu müssen wir aber diese sache hier als extra extra component
machen weil ansonsten kann ich das hier nicht mehrfach verwenden also machen wir extra component
für lip für diesen icon browser icon browser 12 so und dann wird copy pasted der gesamte
icon browser was ist denn alles der icon browser das da eigentlich ne ne von dem diff bis zu
und das da ne das da ist der icon browser overlay danke für den sub so das hier ist
der icon browser ah wisst ihr ich hab ne idee wisst ihr was wir noch machen können rounded
können wir es noch machen rounded rounded top doch gleich viel schöner oder leute rounded
ecken pock pock ecken so das müssen wir jetzt in extra component machen so und die component
heißt icon browser ah jawoll sehr schön was noch keinen einfluss hat weil es in der component
noch nix gibt du du du du so icon browser kommt das da rein zack icon filter gibts nicht
script let icon filter gleich ne nicht gleich icon filter interessiert mich dass der filter
kram irgendwie außerhalb ne wahrscheinlich nicht kann man das kann man das importen so
virtual list kommt hier raus virtual list kommt hier raus da oben drüber einfügen dann
brauchen wir noch die icons so chunkers so ok das sieht doch schon besser aus filtert
icons brauchen wir jetzt noch wo kommt das her filtert icons filtert icons kommt daher
eigentlich kann ich mir das alles mal copy pasten und hier rausschmeißen bis auf show
icon browser das brauchen wir dann später noch mal kurz hier reinkloppen also icon filter
ist leer show icon browser kommt weg so filtert icons schon mal besser ok das einfügen funktioniert
zwar natürlich noch nicht weil das event nicht weitergeleitet wird aber jetzt haben
wir schon mal eine extra component und das ist ein bisschen ordentlich ja es ist doch
deutlich übersichtlicher jetzt den kram hier als das da gut insert icon on click ne da
müssen wir in event weitergeben das weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht wie funktioniert das
ins welt event event event forwarding event event forwarding event detail texts was ich
checks nicht was bin ich hier sehend inner was die katz da macht wo macht die katz was
über dem chat die guckt auf euch runter
in this case we have to
keine ahnung was die mir hiermit sagen wollen
hier on message einfach weitergeben easy also im prinzip hätten sie auch gleich sagen
können im prinzip gebe ich einfach nur on click weiter fertig sonst nix oder so und
jetzt gebe ich on click weiter das bedeutet hier sage ich jetzt an der stelle wo der icon
browser ist click on click ja easy spukige musik hier und dann sage ich das da drinnen
parent so oh nee mist warum funktioniert es nicht weil achso e moment fuck nee ich muss
ich brauche doch ein custom event ich brauche doch ein custom event also wie macht man events
dispatcher create event dispatch ok was auch immer das machen wir jetzt einfach mal so
wie es da steht dispatcher create event dispatcher kann man es importieren nee import genau lass
mich das mal importieren dispatch say hello function function so wie soll das event heißen
icon nee oder was weiß ich selected nennen wir das jetzt einfach on wie ist denn hier
naming convention für keine ahnung select icon icon so so text es gibt einfach nur das
icon als event das kann man wahrscheinlich schöner machen so und jetzt sagen wir hier
on click ich hoffe das ergibt sinn was ich hier mache so on click select icon icon ok
und jetzt müsste ich hier im parent einen on selected haben genau on selected icon so
was fuck warum funktioniert es nicht anzeige ist
raus was mache ich falsch was mache ich falsch was was stimmt hier nicht wird das event überhaupt
geworfen name ja das event wird moment das ist nicht das hä das ist nicht mein argument
was ich übergebe moment detail in details ist ach in details ist das drinne ok also
ist das dann monka es man also brauche ich das gar nicht und das ist das standard event
was man bekommt jetzt wird es aber jetzt wird es aber wir die detail icon ok ergibt
passt passt ja icon ok das brauche ich also ist das hier event das brauche ich ein name
so jetzt sollte es funktionieren wieder fack warum ach nee event keck wait ah da ist es
wieder ok allah schwere geburt schwere geburt aber ich hab ich hab events auch so gut wie
gar nicht bisher benutzt gut jetzt haben wir eine extra komponente für den icon browser
er geht auf und zu er ist schnell man kann suchen und ich kann dieses overlay für alles
andere benutzen deswegen ist es jetzt auch nicht show icon browser sondern keine ahnung
show chat gute idee für namen wie heiß könnte die variable heiß um dieses options menu einfach
warum warum warum nennen wir es nicht show shape browser oder so options option browser
oder show element browser sowas show icon browser ok keck show so jetzt können wir
das machen was wir vorher machen wollen nachdem wir jetzt das in der eigenen komponente ausgelagert
haben brauche ich an der stelle hier nicht mehr diesen ganzen code und kann dieses options
menu options menu oder es ist ja nicht wirklich ein options menu für alles mögliche verwenden
zum beispiel um text einzufügen ich würde sagen text einfügen ist erstmal so mit leute
wir brauchen dann auch wir brauchen auch noch nen emoji menu oder mdi icons alleine reichen
nicht wir brauchen emojis auf den auf den etiketten aber das machen wir nicht jetzt
mal jetzt erstmal text text so also icon browser brauchen wir nicht wir wollen text einfügen
insert text ich glaube das gibt es als funktion noch gar nicht das ist das ist so wir was
ich hier gebaut habe das muss ich unbedingt alles ein bisschen aufspielen insert text
so insert text wenn man das hier klickt so insert text insert text macht auf jeden fall
schon mal das da auf und zu moment nicht insert icon alter insert text insert text ist ja das
was passiert moment moment jetzt muss ich mal kurz überlegen ne ne ne ne ne show element
browser ne ich brauche ne funktion open open element browser so und dann muss ich einstellen
für was irgendwie menu oder sowas weil ich muss das jetzt ja umstellen können ich muss
das jetzt ja umstellen auf icons oder auf text so element browser das das muss auch
als eigene komponente dann gemacht werden ja was weiß ich menu so standardmäßig ist
es nix ist es leer ok gibt das sinn was ich da was ich da baue weil ich muss jetzt ja
anhand der ja doch ich muss jetzt anhand das menüs auswählen was da reinkommt im
endeffekt also anstatt überall wo ich das jetzt von hand reingeschrieben habe also
hier kommt das weg überall wo ich das jetzt von hand reingeschrieben habe muss ich jetzt
sagen show element browser und dann in dem fall für icon oder icons oder so wo ist das
problem is not callable wie warum nicht eigentlich open bescheuerte benahmung deswegen sollte
man das nicht schon also ist das müsste man ist nennen das ist das ist sinnvoller also
nicht show element sondern ist element browser open oder sowas ist das ist das ding hat
einen scheißen armer das brauchen ordentlich das dann erkennt man nämlich auch was es
ist ok funktioniert noch alles ja ok nice auf und zu funktioniert noch gachi bass text
inserten ok wenn man hier klickt soll das umstellen auf open element für text und jetzt
brauchen wir eine extra component für icon browser und jetzt keine ahnung ich nenne
es jetzt einfach text text browser wie auch immer so text browser gibt es natürlich
noch nicht das legen wir jetzt gerade mal an new file text browser ordentlich groß groß
klein kleines welt text browser keck weh whoops was habe ich jetzt gemacht ohje hat
es irgendwas schlimmes hat es jetzt jetzt alles zerstört so text browser text browser
so was ist was ist denn jetzt schon wieder ah noob schon besser toggle element browser
ja er toggelt ja nicht nur es moment ich weiß was der macht es ist nicht open es ist eigentlich
switch kategorie oder sowas kann man machen so also jetzt schaltet er das um von obs das
ist falsch falsche stelle so das schaltet es jetzt um von icons zu text ok nice und open
sollte auch wirklich open sein ja so das heißt das muss ich hier auswählen if kann man das
dann irgendwie schöner machen anstatt jetzt hier einfach in if rein zu klatschen also
if element browser menü gleich gleich icons dann das da das muss doch irgendwie schöner
gehen oder else text browser zum beispiel case nee an der stelle geht kein case so guck
jetzt kann ich zwischen den zwei dingern umschalten hier leht er das den für icons und hier leht
er das für text und da können wir jetzt rein basteln was wir wollen also was brauche
ich denn moment unselected unselected insert text icons und und icon browser nee das funktioniert
nicht das hier ist html mit markup zeug zumindest funktioniert es an der stelle das heißt jetzt
müssen wir irgendwie uns überlegen wie wir das schick machen text text inserten also
wie bauen wir das auf den icon browser hat oben eine suchbar eine suchbar für text ist
glaube ich ziemlich ziemlich useless aber ich kopiere ich kopiere es mir trotzdem mal kurz
so chunk brauchen wir nicht icon filter brauchen wir nicht so selected brauchen wir aber als
event icons brauchen wir wahrscheinlich auch nicht virtual list brauchen wir wahrscheinlich
auch nicht so diff den input brauchen wir den input nee den input brauchen wir auch
nicht ok also was kommt in das diff rein also text also was brauchen wir wir brauchen ein
text was haltet ihr davon wenn wir was ganz simples machen quasi text header so was text
was wir einmal in der vorlage machen für header text für text normal und text schmoll
so und dementsprechend kriegt das jetzt auch die passenden klassen text xl und wenn man
das dann anklickt edit das hier drauf jetzt müssen wir so noch überlegen wie man die
raustufen des textes umstellt und wie man den text editierbar macht vielleicht machen
wir doch ein input hier oben hin let text vielleicht machen wir doch hier oben was hin
ich glaube das ist gar nicht so schlecht und define ist vielleicht doof ja dann sieht man
nämlich gleich was man einfügen würde das ist doch schon mal gar nicht verkehrt so text
normal text schmoll oder den drop down menu mit verschiedenen größen ja sowas in der
richtung ist das ja du siehst du siehst das und kannst es dann anklicken oder erscheint
hier drauf mit bold vielleicht noch ja das könnte man könnte man als alternative anbieten
noch ja müssen wir gleich mal müssen wir gleich mal gucken also klas normal ist text
medium ne text m oder large sekunde lg oder mt ist es lg lg mlg legit xl ne nicht xl sm
so da das ist zu klein oder niemand will sowas kleines auf dem etikett haben das sieht doch
keine sau das ist das ist nicht keck weit das ist nicht zu erkennen sehr was wir machen
wir machen das anders wir lassen text text leer jetzt steht da zwar an die feinden jetzt
war mal oder oder text header ja so ist das schöner oder oder text normal oder oder
text small jetzt müssen wir noch die klammer an die richtigen stelle machen ja so wenn
ich jetzt was eingeben bei spiel text dann kann ich es anklicken schau dir mal den tailwind
editor an ich brauche irgendwas was man hier einfach reinhauen kann aber also jetzt irgendwie
super krassen was denn den da eben super feature reichen das meinst du nicht super feature
reichen text editor muss ja nicht sein das reicht doch eigentlich schon text bspw text
die coolen leute nehmen lorem ipsum bei sowas oder die die sagen hat es hat es wischl hat
es wischl studio code nicht mittlerweile eingebaut so text header text normal text aber text
small ist blöd wir machen lieber text small ist lg und xl ist normal oder 2xl oder xl
ist normal und text small ist so ansonsten ist das viel zu fett wie wäre es mit zwei
buttons um die font size einfach selbst vergrößern zu können und zu verkleinern ja wir brauchen
da oben e-buttons leute wir brauchen wir brauchen keine suchleiste wir brauchen wir brauchen
was für graustufen wir brauchen was für die graustufen wir brauchen so einen kleinen
color selector hier oben noch jetzt müssen wir mal ausprobieren ob wir da irgendwas gescheites
hinkriegen hier diff class flex weird flex diff class 12 12 bg grey gibt geile color picker
ich weiß aber ich brauch kein color picker ich brauch drei drei ich brauch fünf fünf
buttons mit unterschiedlichen grautönen das ist glaube ich zu grautöne picker im dark
theme das können schwierig werden ja rot geht nicht der etikettendrucker ist schwarz
weiß oder soll ich einfach color einfügen weil man color einfügen kann deswegen ist
es ja auch alles graustufen weiße konturen ja wir können border machen tatsächlich border
und wir machen das mal ein bisschen kleiner immer dran wir müssen das mobile auch anklicken
können wir müssen das wir müssen das auch mobile anklicken können ein slider ein slider
für die schriftgröße ist eigentlich ganz cool ja also was machen wir denn für farben
ich mein vier farben oder so reichen ja das hängt dann so schön in der ecke hier oben
vielleicht ein bisschen größer ich glaube auf dem smartphone ist das zu klein was haben
wir sonst zu bieten acht neun zehn elf zehn vielleicht rot grün blau weiß wie gesagt
der etikettendrucker ist schwarz weiß es macht eigentlich außer dass es im web interface
optisch schöner aussieht macht es keinen sinn farben anzubieten
also graustufen soll wir machen wir machen eine relativ helle so wir machen quasi weiß
so weiß dann irgendwie mittel und dann bisschen dunkler und dann sieben oder das reicht ganz
ehrlich leute mehr braucht man nicht an graustufen das ist ausreichend
weiß ist doch bullshit naja warum vielleicht möchte man so was in hintergrund machen dann
weiße schrift drauf und ein ganz schwarz ja das ist tatsächlich
sinnvoll bg black ja das doch ok finde ich schick finde ich echt in ordnung wie das ausschaut
so jetzt müssen wir noch sagen kürzer pointer hier drauf kürzer pointer
mal wie ging das in der studio noch mal alt ne moment alt wie macht man mehrere kürzer
noch mal kontrol plus feil was kontrol es ist alt es ist alt so sieht doch eigentlich
ganz hübsch aus jetzt können wir noch die color uns speichern oben so color
oder mit mausrad kann man rechtecke markieren was echt wie auch immer
so also text header normal so da muss noch ein bisschen ein bisschen abstand dazwischen
und margin bottom 2 bisschen mehr abstand hängt so aufeinander so das reicht doch als
text auswahl oder wollen wir wirklich noch einen button machen für schriftgröße größer
und kleiner eigentlich ist das minimalistisch genug so du kannst hier oben reinschreiben
keck wie alda lan oder so dann kannst du dann die farbe anklicken und dann klickst
hier unten drauf und dann hast du dein text muss doch muss doch eigentlich soweit eigentlich
soweit passen testen wir mal ob das mit dem hinzufügen denn überhaupt funktioniert also
ich gebe zu das ist usability technisch der label der label maker kann farbig nein kann
er nicht der kann nur graustufen deswegen haben nur graustufen am start und selektor
ich weiß nicht font selektor das ist aber ganz schön advanced ich wüsste gar nicht
wie man den drop down irgendwie gescheit macht wie lässt man sich mit java script überhaupt
alle verfügbaren fonts auflisten weiß ich gar nicht js list fonts geht das überhaupt
bestimmt die leute wollen bestimmt comic sans drucken ich kann es mir jetzt schon vorstellen
und face set check ok das geht nicht weil fingerprinting das geht nicht weil fingerprinting
ok da muss ich meine eigenen fonts meine muss irgendwelche web fonts mit liefern ich habe
noch nie web fonts included viele für sowas das braucht auch viel zu viel speicher benutzt
google fonts das probieren wir aus machen wir gleich ich will erstmal gucken ob das
adden prinzipiell funktioniert kursor pointer so zack zack ja die usability ist noch nicht
so ganz da aber aber aber schauen wir mal select none ok ist noch nicht so die hyper
usability so wie ich mir das vorstelle aber ok ich will jetzt testen ob das funktioniert
wenn man das wenn man das anklickt on on click das ist kein search achso da steht noch
ein search drin text what on click select icon ist schon mal verkehrt select text text
meinte text muss ich übergeben den text habe ich da oben stehen select text text text wobei
so reicht doch text ja ja unexpected token darf nicht rum ok der sollt jetzt der sollt
jetzt das event schmeißen oder sollt jetzt das event schmeißen das probieren wir mal
aus also insert text sollte der jetzt und selected machen insert text macht er das
denn insert text der wirft kein event warum nicht moment click text was mache ich denn
dafür ein select text man nicht text jetzt wirft er auch das event ok so und wie fügt
man jetzt text ein lass lass mich mal raten ok lass mal ran let und insert text das ist
hier der text jetzt bräuchte ich beide beides mal text text text shape gleich new konver
text aha tja text konfig kek wait keine ahnung konver text zeig her wie funktioniert's ich
brauch ein example tutorial tutorial text please text text so was da will ich haben text auch
als svg ich glaube das macht er standardmäßig als svg dann kann man es theoretisch noch
auf dem canvas resizing dann wenn man das auf dem canvas resizing kann brauche ich
hier gar nicht in unterschiedlichen größen sondern vielleicht mit unterschiedlichen styles
das werden wir gleich sehen hier text shape moment das hier ist ja auch gar nicht so
das ist ja gar nicht der text das hier ist das event event und es ist let text als was
data kek wait viel besser nennen wir es so text hier mein text so font size haben wir
keine auswahl 30 kalibri was auch immer green nein ja das müssen wir noch mit übergeben
machen wir noch nicht schauen wir mal ob das insorten jetzt wenigstens funktioniert nee
ach so weil ich kein text gesetzt habe aber ich muss ich muss ich muss insorten layer
add text shape ja möglichkeit zum resizen haben wir kann es sein moment ich ich ich
trau das oben links in der ecke dann finde ich es wenigstens wieder wartet mal lock text
shape ach detail icon schön copy pasted ja das immer moment selectable ja content das
brauche ich weil irgendwie mein eigener shit so
tracable tracable true so ja man kann hier resizen ist das times new roman nee das ist
das kalibri igitt gehst du mal fort alter bäh das will ich nicht haben so wir müssen
jetzt die farbe noch übergeben sonst funktioniert das nicht also selected text haben wir wir
machen standard beispiel beispiel text da rein weil wenn text leer ist wie wie fängt
das an bacon sehr schön bacon das heißt wenn ich das jetzt anklick ohne dass was aus
ausgewählt ist ach ich das habe ich die ganze zeit gesucht ich dachte das sieht man hier
als als nee kann man nicht ist das ein addon wie machen das das muss mein html machen das
geht nicht in ja was kannst du mein html machen ok da fand ich das bacon aber besser bacon
pepo fett so und wenn ich jetzt hier was reinschreibe dann geht das ok grün ist jetzt einfach
nur weil man es besser sieht der tag der drucker kann kein grün ok also dann brauchen wir
hier noch ok ich übergebe mal font weil ich keine ahnung habe ob wir das ein implementieren
werden font und color color übergebe ich in ja wie kriege ich eigentlich die color jetzt
so ich habe jetzt da drauf geklickt so ich klicke jetzt auf meine colors und jetzt brauche
ich ja theoretisch noch noch function irgendwie sowas wie color kann man den text nachträglich
editieren aktuell noch nicht aber ich habe mir überlegt man könnte es ja so machen
dass wenn man den text anklickt und dieses menü hier aufmacht man das hier einfach ausgefüllt
bekommt und die standard dinge halt ändern kann wenn schon eingefügt ist wieder live
ja so color wie kriege ich denn jetzt die color hier her was ist das überhaupt für
eine color ah obviously rgb2 durch was ne das da das da brauchen wir das ist meine color
on click kann man das so machen color gleich ne wait a minute ach ne ich muss das doppelt
quaten funktioniert das dann überhaupt anscheinend noch anderlei etat ja also guck mal man kann
die größte ja hiermit beeinflussen leute deswegen eigentlich brauchen wir dieses text
normal und so gar nicht sondern wir können im prinzip sagen text also text text eigentlich
nur text weil text normal und so brauchen wir nicht ok text normal
so text bold ne font bold ist das glaube ich so bold und was denn sonst noch underline
oder oder was 2xl reicht glaube ich ansonsten wobei 3xl ist schon gut was haben wir sonst
auch zu bieten font underline ne gibt es gar nicht
ich weiß gar nicht wie man das in tailwind tailwind underline font text decoration man
könnte auch icons machen da hast du recht ja vielleicht sogar besser einfach underline
wait a minute warum ist es font bold und nicht font underline
man sieht die underline einfach nicht wegen den icons unten keck keck wait vielleicht machen
wir da wirklich icons wir machen ja noch icons daneben für bold aber wobei zum testen das
ist erstmal durchaus ok so
das heißt wir müssen uns das jetzt merken boah echt leute ich mach mal nur bold da hab
ich nur 2 sachen zum abfackeln jetzt da müsste man sich noch den style merken aber viel wichtiger
wie kriege ich das mit der color hin package lock ne im moment nicht package lock du meinst
moment meinst du meinst du package lock jetzt irgendwie rpm technisch oder meinst du npm
mäßig du meinst npm mäßig ne ich mach auf der arbeit nix mit node wirklich also
ich geh mal davon aus ja aber ich weiß es nicht ich mach nix mit node auf der arbeit
과
Also das da, das da setzt jetzt die Color.
Testen wir mal ob das auch wirklich die Color setzt.
Lock Color, das setzt die Color.
So jetzt muss ich Color übergeben.
Color, so also von der Idee her bekomme ich jetzt hier noch, noch ein, ein Color im Mode,
habe ich im Mode Color im Event mitgeschickt.
Schauen wir mal ob es das auch funktioniert.
Also ich klick das hier an, sag Text normal, Color, ja hier passt.
Ok und nun wie gebe ich die Color hier an?
Phil, kann man das als RGB Wert angeben, da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Color, wahrscheinlich nicht, wahrscheinlich muss ich jetzt erstmal RGB Wert zu Hex Schreibweise
machen oder sowas.
Nee es funktioniert.
Es funktioniert Leute.
Kunst, PogChamp, Moment, warum ist der Selektor dahinter?
Mein Selektor ist da, der ist da, was macht der da?
Der ist weg, ok man erkennt es auch nicht wirklich.
Gut, also das heißt im Prinzip funktioniert das ganze schon mal, also sagen wir OnClick,
OnClick, OnClick, OnClick, so und dann haben wir hier Color, RGB oder RGB wie die coolen
Leute sagen, das da und das da, achja Default, Default brauchen wir ja auch noch, so und
das da, wobei das ist einfach, das wollte ich gerade sagen, das ist 000, das ist tatsächlich
easy.
So und wenn ich da jetzt was schreibe, lulululul, schwarz, das da, BÄM, nice guckt mal, es
funktioniert.
Was ist, das ist schick, das gefällt mir, meine Usability technisch ist das noch nicht,
da war jetzt das letzte Schluss, ja da muss man ehrlich sagen, da muss man noch was besseres
einfallen.
Ja zum Beispiel müssen wir das hier noch selecten, was ausgewählt ist, also anstatt
das wir Border so machen, machen wir jetzt mal beispielsweise Border Blue, irgendwie so,
ja das es selected ist, guckt mal, also das man weiß was selected ist, 400, 400 war schon
ok ja, ne 500, also das man weiß was selected ist, vielleicht sollte man den Border sogar
ein bisschen größer machen, ja so ist gut oder, dann erkennt man wenigstens was selected
ist, dann erkennt man wenigstens was selected ist, ja, so wie merke ich mir denn jetzt was
selected ist, das ist ja, das ist ja richtig eklig, oder im gleichen Pinkton wie die Buttons,
das ist auch eine gute Idee, das testen wir mal, Pink, 500 ist das glaube ich, ne 600,
damit Pink können wir den Border auch kleiner machen, haben wir 3, ne gibt es nicht oder,
gibt es nur, kann ich sagen Border, Sekunde, 3 sowas, eh 3, Magenta Border, ja ich glaube
so ist es ganz ok oder, Leute 4 oder 2 Border und Blau oder Magenta, kann man auch 8 Border
machen, dann sieht man gar nichts mehr, Abmahnung, das ist nicht Magenta, das ist Pink, 600,
2 Magenta, 4 Magenta, ja, so mal schauen, eh wie merke ich mir denn jetzt, dass das
aktiviert wurde, ich mein die Obvious Variante wäre, ähm, Color, äh wäre Border, aber
das ist doof, pack die Color Buttons doch in eine eigene Komponente und lass die per
Each ausgeben, gib jedem die ID E und gib ihm Class Select, oh 5 Head Time, Leute, Big
Brain Time, jetzt gehts aber ab, die Buttons kriegen die ID, ja Moment, das mit der ID
ist doch eigentlich viel besser, wir machen das mit der ID hier drin auch, wir merken
uns was in Color Selected ist, merken wir uns die ID und hier drinnen in dem Event mappen
wir dann die ID auf die eigentliche Color, das ist glaube ich sinnvoller, also das wäre
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, das ist Color 1, Leute fangen wir bei 0 oder bei 1 an, eigentlich
ist es egal, das ist Color 1, das ist Color 2, das ist Color 3, das ist Color 4, das ist
Color 5, kann man aus Javascript abfragen, ne das krieg ich da nicht gescheit raus, so
und jetzt kann ich nämlich auch sagen, if, kurz weg, Class Border Pink, 500, 600, gibt
das wenn Color gleich gleich 1 ist, ob das funktioniert, hey, schuld dass nur die ID
hängen geblieben ist, ja das mit der Komponente machen wir vielleicht noch, oh was jetzt?
ja also, ID 3, ID 4, ID 5.
So, jetzt kann man den Krempel auch selecten, so ist das doch eigentlich ganz nice, wie findest
du Edabit, was, Programming, Edabit, hab ich noch nie gehört, Coding Practice Challenge,
keine Ahnung, hab ich noch nie gehört, sagt mir nix, dann steht leider nix zu sagen, so,
so ist doch ganz schick, so und jetzt müssen wir das hier drinnen machen, wie macht man
das jetzt mit dem Switch, wie macht man das am schönsten, einfach ein if, oder, if Color
gleich gleich 1, oh ne da war ein extra Funktion draus, Color ID 2 RGB, if Color gleich 1,
Return, oder macht man das mit nem Switch, mit nem Switch ist besser oder, Switch, Color,
Value 1, Return, ähm, tja ich weiß es nicht mehr Leute, von oben nach unten wahrscheinlich,
so was da, ist das, ist das da, The Javascript Way Leute das zu machen, ok 2, 3, 4, 5, oh
jetzt als nächstes haben wir, ne Map, jawoll, wir könnten, wir machen, wir machen ne Map,
auf der anderen Seite, ob ich jetzt ne Map ausfülle oder, ich mein wir könnten, Color
Map, mal gucken, mal gucken was schöner ist, mal gucken, mal gucken was schöner ist, wobei
keine Map, wir machen nen Array, wir machen nen Array, weil ne Map mit nem Index, ne Map
mit nem Indizier, also des bescheuert, wir machen nen Array, so, zack, erstes Element,
nulltes Element, da müssen wir es auf null, null ändern gleich, so was haben wir als nächstes,
das da, äh, das da, seht ihr eigentlich wie Fivehead mein Clipboard Manager ist, dass
er das da unten wegnimmt und da oben hinschreibt, so, so, dann muss nämlich die IDs, dann muss
ich die IDs noch ändern, null, ich sehe schon, das mit eigener Komponente war doch nicht
so, nicht so blöd, was der Chat vorgeschlagen hat, welcher Clipboard Manager, äh, Rofi,
Rofi Clip, so und jetzt kann ich einfach sagen, return, Color Map, es ist ja nicht wirklich
Color Map, Colors, es ist einfach Colors, so, äh, ID, so, so und wenn ich das jetzt
ordentlich gemacht habe, sollte ich bei Color eigentlich jetzt die Farbe zurückbekommen,
ok, bla, bla, bla, bla, das da, das da, geht, PogChamp, guck mal, nice, Funst und ist wieder
erwartend sogar relativ lesbar, oder, finde, das kann man ziemlich gut lesen, was hier passiert,
vielleicht soll ich es anstatt hier Color tatsächlich nochmal Color ID nennen, weil
hier, ich nenne es hier überall Color ID, Moment, Multiple Cursors, Multiple Fivehats,
bam, jawoll, nice, so, jetzt müssen wir noch übertragen, jetzt müssen wir noch, ähm,
hinschreiben ob bold oder nicht, ok Chat, was haltet, also Schriftgröße brauchen wir
nicht, oder, hatten wir doch gesagt, Schriftgröße ist unsinnig, also Schriftgröße, Schriftgröße
ist unsinnig, weil Schriftgröße können wir damit einstellen, vielleicht machen wir
doch, wir machen einen Fontselektor, da muss ich mir aber erstmal überlegen, Google, irgendjemand
hat gesagt, Google Fonts, müssen wir uns gleich machen, wir machen, ich habe noch nie einen
Fontselektor gemacht, erstmal gucken wie das funktioniert, ähm, Chat, wisst ihr, was
noch viel Fiveheadiger wäre, was richtig massive Fiveheadig wäre, aber ich nicht weiß ob sich
der Aufwand lohnt, eigentlich wäre es doch viel sinnvoller, man würde den Text gar nicht
hier eintragen, sondern, man würde immer Text normal hier drauf droppen und dann könnte
man das hier oben doppelt anklicken und dann hier oben drinnen editieren, da weiß ich
aber nicht wie es geht, da müsste man irgendeinen Textbox Overlay machen oder sowas, wir bleiben
jetzt erstmal dabei, weil da weiß ich, dass das funktioniert, könnte am Ende komisch
aussehen, wenn du die Größe immer per Hand machst und dann eventuell keinen Unterschied
hast, was, du kannst Content Edible machen, nee kann ich nicht, weil das hier oben ist
ein Canvas, was gemalt wird im Hintergrund von Conva, das ist kein HTML Element, das
ist Canvas, deswegen kann man da auch solche Sachen mit machen hier, was du mit HTML Elementen
hier machen kannst, Small Text, die Library direkt kann das nicht, die sagen, man soll
im Textbox Overlayen, das mach ich vielleicht dann irgendwann mal noch, aber nicht jetzt
gleich, ok zack, Leute ich muss euch sagen, der Chat verleitet mich dazu Sachen relativ
ordentlich zu programmieren, jetzt mach ich das da außen vor, so, Default Color ID ist
0 und dann ist auch die hier selected, das heißt standardmäßig inserte ich das mit
weiß, das ist ziemlich blöd, die standard Color ID sollte 4 sein, Schwatz, ok, wie kriegen
wir da jetzt einen Font Selector hin, irgendjemand eine Big Brain Idee, wir machen zwar, wir
machen zwar, du bist immer noch für 3 Buttons, Bold Italic Underline, ok, dann machen wir
das noch, weil es der Chat ist, wie macht es eigentlich Canva.com, von denen kann man
bisschen UI klauen, wie machen die das eigentlich, wie machen die das eigentlich, Text, ok die
machen das, Dark Reader macht es kaputt, ja die machen es auch so, boah ich glaube das
ist mega aufwendig sowas hier zu machen, dass du das hier drinnen editieren kannst,
NPM für Font Picker brauche ich nicht, ach die haben hier oben so eine Leiste, die haben
hier oben so eine Leiste und hier kann man dann, ach so machen die das, ok, das ist natürlich
auch clever, Chat vielleicht sollte ich meine Menüs auch so machen, auf dem Desktop so
und auf dem Smartphone so, ist vielleicht die clevere Idee, weil auf dem Desktop hast
du hier Platz und auf dem Smartphone hast du hier Platz, das kann man sogar relativ
easy machen, das ist ein bisschen CSS und Viewports und sowas, also so, das schreibe
ich mir auf, das schreibe ich mir auf fürs nächste Mal, also wir bleiben noch eine Weile
on, aber das mache ich heute nicht, hier, Icon Browser, aber hier, keine Ahnung, to do,
responsive, LG gleich Menu Left, Smartphone Menu Bottom, irgendwie so, Kellner Kai, danke
schön für den, ah nee, ist gar kein Sub, aber schön dass du den Weg her gefunden hast,
hab ich mal geguckt, übrigens Subscriptions habe ich mir schon wieder die Hälfte übersehen,
Sekunde, BartenderEnter hat Subscribed, danke schön, Overlay, Tanser, BloodSnake, danke
Leute für die Subs, voll verdrängt, so, wisst ihr was, ich finde den Standardrahmen,
ehrlich gesagt, in weiß, nein Max, wir halten uns jetzt nicht an die Color von den Rahmen
in der Textbox auf, das machen wir jetzt nicht, wir machen jetzt Font Selection, nee, nee,
nee, machen wir nicht, wir machen erst noch Bold Italic, sonst was, ok, also, da brauchen
wir noch was hier, neben dran würde ich sagen, oder Chat, quasi noch mal hier neben dran,
was brauchen wir da, was habt ihr gesagt, Bold Italic Underline, also das würde ich
quasi sagen, Let, irgendwie Style, gleich, Nix ausgewählt, Moment, das ist, das ist
gar nicht so einfach, das brauchen wir, weil du kannst ja mehrere Styles zusammen machen,
New Set, oh, Fiveheader, Fiveheader Time, Set, MonkaS, ok, mal schauen, ich mach mal
kurz das On-Click weg, das blick ich da nicht mehr durch, so, das ist da auch weg, so, und
es hat keinen Rahmen, ich brauch ein eigen Material Design Icon für Italic, oder nee,
Bold, brauchen wir, Bold, ja, Seite, Please, funktionieren, High Speed Seite, die gibt
es nicht, Underline, Ach, Format, Format, Underline, was haben wir denn da, Underline
und dann, wo, wo ist, wo ist Italic, verstehe ich jetzt nicht, da muss es doch Icons für
geben, Italic und wo ist Bold, gibt es, ah, ok, dann ist, dann ist easy, also, SVG, wir
haben eine Icon Library, aber, vor ich da jetzt wieder rumwurschteln, mach ich das lieber
erstmal einfach so von der Hand rein, so, also, Diff, Content, da, Flex, Align Center,
nee, Align, Ach, wie ging das nochmal, Justify Center, Justify Center und Items Center, jawoll,
sehr gut, was brauchen wir jetzt sonst noch, Format, Italic, SVG, so, Copy Paste wir uns
den Krempel mal, ok, und was als letztes noch, was hatte ich nicht, Bold, Italic, Underline,
ok, Massive F-Zero Musik, so, Programmieren gleich Copy und Paste, ja, öfters als man
denkt, das sieht ziemlich kacke aus mit dem Rahmen drum herum, oder, das sieht ziemlich
pains-champelig aus, aber, was willst du machen, mir fällt da grad wenig ein, vielleicht machen
wir das ne Zeile unten drunter, vielleicht machen wir das ne Zeile unten drunter, oh,
ja, wozu eigentlich ein Component Based Framework, weil ich JavaScript Noob bin und das ich ganz
bestimmt nicht mit reinem Vanilla JS hinkriege, so, wirklich schicker finde ich das jetzt
auch nicht wenn ich ehrlich bin, ich mach das was der Chat sagt, der Chat meinte, wir
splitten das irgendwie auf, also quasi, Chat wie meint ihr das so, das so aufsplitten,
so, und das andere dann rechts, oder wie, oder wo, oder was, in Parent Div, einfach
justify between adden, ok, wenn der Chat das sagt, dann muss das stimmen, hatte der Chat
schon jemals unrecht, Leute, justify between, aha, naja, ok, Leute, zum testen reicht's,
schön machen können wir das immer noch, wir dürfen uns jetzt nicht so viel mit gebastelt
hier aufhalten, so, also jetzt können wir noch Underline Italic Bold machen, so, und
wenn man das jetzt klicken, wenn man das jetzt klicken, dann passiert folgendes, wenn
wir jetzt hier anklicken, Underline, dann passiert hier oben, haben wir nämlich style, add, underline,
und jetzt, select, das ist usability, echt nicht schön, style, includes, ne, wie kann
man checken, Moment, js map includes, wie geht das, has, has, ok, has, underline, ok,
das funktioniert nicht, warum nicht, bestimmtfalls Weltlogik, bestimmtfalls Weltlogik, ich wusste
es, ich wusste es, Textball kommt weg, brauchen wir nicht mehr, ok, das muss in der eigenen
Component, das ist nicht mehr händelbar, so langsam, ich blicke nicht mehr durch, too
much untereinander, bold, aber wisst ihr was das cool ist, ich kann jetzt mehrere selecten
und von den Farben, von den Farben kann ich nur eins selecten, ist nice, oder, hier kann
ich mehrere selecten, aber nicht anselecten, warum nicht anselecten, weil ich nicht, oh
ne, please, das ist eklig, ich muss es removeen, wenn es schon drin ist, also ich muss quasi
sagen, if, boah, if has bold, also sprich, wenn es schon, wenn es schon hinzugefügt ist,
dann muss ich sagen, style, remove, ne, delete, delete ist es, ja, ja, ja, es funktioniert,
ok, nice, boah, ist das, i get, can't wait, man, zack, ihr seht, programmieren ist copy
pasten, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, ne, zack, zack, zack, ok, ich kann, fuck, was
ist jetzt, nein, hier soll ich italien, so, jetzt kann ich selecten und kann anselecten,
nice, huge, massive leiste hier, und color kann ich nur eine selecten, so, so muss das
sein, alles klar, ah, Moment, wir können tatsächlich ne Funktion machen, das ist eigentlich total
hängen geblieben, das nicht als extra Funktion zu machen, chat, warum sagt ihr denn nichts,
wir brauchen ne extra Funktion, toggle, style, style oder name, das kann man doch bestimmt
auch schöner machen, oder, has, ne, aber bei, fällt mir jetzt grad nix anderes ein, einfach
string, pass und gg, was, keine Ahnung, so, jetzt machen wir nämlich, anstatt das hier,
schreiben wir jetzt einfach rein, so, underline, schauen wir mal, ob es funktioniert, ja, easy,
easy, jetzt können wir nämlich diesen ganzen Mist hier ersetzen, bold italic, und es funktioniert
immer noch, so, so ist gut, nice, so, aber eigentlich wollten wir uns ja angucken, wie
man verschiedene Schriften macht, da bin ich jetzt wirklich ein bisschen planlos, ich mache
mir zwar einfach testweise hier unten, ich mach mir jetzt testweise mal drei Buttons,
so, areal, das ist nur zum ausprobieren, areal, was brauchen wir sonst noch für ne Schrift,
comic sans, und die keqw Schrift, so, und wenn ich das hier anklicke, nur zum ausprobieren,
wenn ich das hier anklicke, dann sollte sich die Schriftart ändern, ok, wo kriege ich Schriftarten
her, google, google fonts, sagt der Chat, google fonts, ja, return, ich will ja nicht return,
ich will ja unten drunter noch, guck mal, ich will nicht return, ich will unten drunter
noch style gleich style machen, das ist Weltkram, das braucht man, style gleich has name, ah,
wir könnten ein tannery, tannery, tannery, wie auch immer man das ausspricht, operator
machen, also den da, das ist ne gute Idee, tannery, wie spricht man das richtig aus,
pronunciation, tannery, tannery, tannery, ok, ein tannery operator können wir machen,
ob es das dann schöner macht, style gleich has name, wenn ja, Moment, das ist Javascript,
das funktioniert bestimmt oder, nein das funktioniert nicht, das funktioniert nicht, das hat ja
keine return werte das Ding, das muss ich glaube ich so machen, ah ja, ich kann damit
leben, Javascript passt schon, Leerzeichen dazwischen, keine Leerzeichen, ich mag ja
Leerzeichen vor einem if in der, egal, darf man nicht, gut, also, was soll ich machen,
google fonts css import, roboto, roboto ist immer schön, roboto ist immer schön, nimm
zum testen einfach zeichen fonts vom betriebssystem, das ist wohl wahr, let font gleich arial, so,
wie ändert man den font überhaupt, wie ändert man dann den font überhaupt, style, inline
style, jetzt was font, family, ne, Moment, was war ich denn hier, font, family, arial,
ok, easy, also hier font, so, das scheint ja zu funktionieren, also on click, ich vergesse
immer drum herum die geschweiften klammern zu machen, ok font gleich arial, arial, so,
font, roboto und font, was ist die times oder so, ok den in der Mitte hab ich nicht, hab
ich nicht roboto installiert, sag mir mal irgendein font, mono, monospace hab ich auf
jeden fall drauf, font guck mal, arial, comic, uns und times, also von der idee her tut das,
wie macht man das jetzt mit google fonts und die frage ist doch eigentlich viel eher,
ich kann doch jetzt nicht, Leute, ich kann doch jetzt nicht 10, 20 fonts laden, oder,
so ein font ist doch, na wobei, was da du in dem on click keine parameter und nur ein ausdruck
hast würde das auch gehen, font gleich arial und was, discard, so, ne, ah das muss man
klammern, ich lass das erstmal so, weil ich muss da bestimmt noch mehr reinschreiben
gleich, also was ich kenne ist bei font selector ist sowas hier, gucken wir mal an, wie die
das machen hier, rappen wir ein bisschen das user interface von denen mal ab, also die machen
das so, überschrift und dann haben sie so ein drop down mit den fonts, ah die laden
die fonts dynamisch, 5 header time, haben die irgendwie ganz google fonts integriert
oder was, guck mal wer da ist, kennt ihr den, von dem hab ich schon mal was im chat gelesen,
guck mal der lädt das, Leute, der lädt das dynamisch nach, oder, hat google fonts irgendwas
zum preview generieren ohne dass ich die schriftart laden muss, weil da muss ja die vorschau irgendwie
generieren, ich hab das noch nicht, keine ahnung, wie groß die fonts, da weiß ich ordentlich
von den label drucker, wir machen 3 fonts, das reicht Leute, roboto, open sans, monzerat,
was auch immer, roboto ist eh beste font, roboto, roboto medium 500 beste, roboto medium
das will ich haben, selectestyle, css import, style, ah nee, ach moment, null, ah ne, ich
hab das noch nicht, so und was muss ich jetzt specifyen, äh, hä, Leute, warum muss ich
beides, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht, ich kann doch font family nur einmal setzen, warum
muss ich jetzt, ach moment, den hab ich vom letzten mal noch hier drin, den font, wie lösche
ich den dann wieder, font family, roboto, brauch ich, font family, roboto, reicht das
wenn ich das so lade, dass es nicht mehr dsgvo konform war, ach weil google fonts, wisst
ihr, wisst ihr, wie sehr mich das interessiert, ob das dsgvo konform ist oder nicht, also
wollen wir hier mal, anscheinend wollen wir hier roboto, roboto, gibt es irgendeinen coolen
comic fonts, search, comic, comic neue, das, Leute ich sag's euch, dass wir der renner
bei labeldruckern jetzt, nee, nicht robot, roboto, roboto, bam, funst, danke für den
sub, da ist er wieder, max powerq, jetzt wo du da bist, danke für die subs, hast du
immer noch problem mit dotnet, vielleicht können wir dir helfen mit der, fehlermeldung,
warum es bei dir nicht funktioniert unter linux, weil ich, ich kenne ehrlich gesagt
wenig was so problemlos cross platform funktioniert, so roboto funktioniert als font, comic neue,
das brauchen wir, comic, neue, regular, alles klar, dann nicht, roboto, kann ich dir
jetzt eigentlich auch bold machen, font, high IQ chat, jemanden planen, wie macht man das
bold, font, wie macht man den css, so in richtig style css das bold, weil ich kann's einfach
sagen font bold, ist es jetzt dicker als normal, ist das jetzt pepofettiger, sag mal chat kann
das sein, dass ich roboto installiert habe und das deswegen funktioniert, nö, font bold,
ok so jetzt haben wir den text von am start, was brauchen wir dann sonst noch, comic, comics,
ja comics, comic, neue, unbedingt, regular, import, ich importiere jetzt einfach just for
fann massig font krempel weil es geht ok wie heißt das ding comic comic neue neue comic
so also hier comic bamm massive comic so was brauche man sonst noch chat eine ordentliche
schrift art brauche noch irgendwas was richtig gut für impact impact ist glaube ich gut
für labels nie gibt es nicht label in einem guten font für label bresa rief natürlich
ist das gut für label schon oder das hier ziemlich passend für label aus tatsächlich
sehr rief so das haben wir hier das ist ziemlich gut für label das ist ziemlich gut für label
hier oder finde ich nice roboto geht comic ist ehrlich gesagt ziemlicher krabb type right
typewriter typewriter gibt es nicht als font type etikett kategorie also wir haben monospace
font dabei moment ich habe normales roboto genommen ich will roboto mono haben roboto
mono will ich haben 500 ja aber man muss das hier enden ach fai fertig man ändert das
hier und dann generiert es einem so einen bundle ja garamond jetzt kommen die ganzen
h i q f empfehlung medium 500 ja das ist glaube ich nicht verkehrt als label wisterio danke
für den sub ist es der chain law oder ist was anderes jemand anderes max power danke
für noch mal hier gehts aber ab ok selekte style selekte style ok style import ok es
reicht jetzt drei styles sind genug roboto mono ist das hier noch mono oder zusammengeschrieben
ne auseinander so das sind schöne unterschiedliche schriften oder ist das die schrift ist das
die richtige ne das ist nicht die richtige was muss ich angeben das ist nicht die richtige
schrift da sehe ich was anderes weil wenn ich hier mist angebe dann kommt es gleich
heraus wenn ich da drauf klicke warum findet er das jetzt nicht was was mache ich was mache
ich verkehrt muss ich mal neu generieren hatte ich nicht hatte ich nicht generiert da ich
hat es generiert ok die funs nicht im browser oder wie habe ich irgendwas falsch geschrieben
nö oder ist alles richtig keine ahnung lasst ihr schmecken da jetzt weiß ich nicht was
der warum das ist die schrift da nicht mag die mag er nicht wurde der font geladen schauen
wir mal ich mein er wird zumindest hier reingehauen so wo sieht man das in den dev tools hallo
sieht man in den dev tools geladene fonts application net ach hier meinste bei network ob der den
request macht zu google ja gut den request muss er ja machen anscheinend und es habe
ich jetzt gemacht was habe ich jetzt gemacht und wie kriege ich es wieder weg keine ahnung
sei zu neuladen ich weiß wie kriege ich das wieder weg was was so aha also die fonts werden
geladen also warum der font nicht geht verstehe ich nicht muss ich vielleicht font weight
500 oder so noch machen probieren ich trage es mal direkt ein
nö guckt ach moment es hat doch funktioniert oder war das mal das sieht einfach nur ähnlich
aus wie meine default schrift aber das ist doch nicht das ist doch nicht der font hier
das sieht doch ganz anders aus text normal
nee das ist da nicht guck mal hier geht das t in beide richtungen hier geht das t nach
links weil das ist da nicht ok font weight machen wir noch font weight 500
gibt's nicht wird nicht geladen kein bock verstehe ich jetzt nicht aber gut was auch
immer low low iq font loading genau das habe ich angegeben hier
geht nicht also ich check es nicht weil offensichtlich moment das ist der richtige font das ist die
ganze zeit der richtige font das sieht einfach nur klein skaliert nicht so aus ok ist gut
funktioniert funktioniert auch schon die ganze zeit keck weight schon die ganze zeit richtig
gewesen gibt es nicht eine gute api von excalibur habe ich nicht ausprobiert so was was kann
man da jetzt machen wie wird man wie insertet man text und ein try out now achso plus wenn
man was entbinden kann bin ich ja auch dabei
nee gibt keine api gibt keine richtige api oder doch
oh nee i frame api nee hör mal bloß auf ich weiß gar nicht wie man hier text wie insertet
man hier überhaupt text leute doppelklick nee ich glaube der dark reader macht es kaputt
oder ah der dark reader macht es kaputt mich würde interessieren mit was sie das
trauen mit was machen die das ist es in canvas oder ist es webgl oder wie machen die das
weiß man was canvas ok vielleicht mit webgl drunter mal schauen nee aber i frame api ist
crap dann mache ich lieber mein eigenes text ding so gut jetzt kann man schriftart auswählen
wunderbar ja was braucht man mehr oder ist doch ist doch eigentlich ist eigentlich ausreichend
mal eigentlich müsste man so eine art drop down machen für die für die schriftart aber
drop drop down menüs sind so ziemlich das ekligste was es in javascript gibt drop down
das ist richtig ab nicht das da das meine ich nicht select select menü javascript das
ist ganz abhaltig das möchte man eigentlich nicht nicht verwenden guck mal das sieht aus
wie von 1995 und du kannst es nicht richtig style oder doch custom select aber man kann
es eklig style nur excalibur für react ja das ist dann wahrscheinlich aber auch nur
die i frame api gewerbt ach nee das zum selbst hausen oder wie das ist die anwendung komplett
also so einen so einen font option menü ist schon ist schon eklig warte mal select wir
probieren mal was aus so als letzte amtshandlung heute ich kann schon immer richtig denken
wir probieren mal was aus so select da wenn ich das schon sehe wir brauchen ja nur drei
options oder gass nee vielleicht mache ich ja noch ein paar andere fonts keine ahnung
sag mal wie lade ich das jetzt eigentlich coolerweise dynamisch oder ok chat wie ist
das eigentlich wenn ich warte mal wir müssen mal kurz die die die tools an die seite machen
und den browser fullscreen network so ich importiere jetzt ja hier die fonts nee der
lädt alle fonts egal ob ich die an anklicken oder nicht es ist egal ob ich die anklicken
oder nicht warte mal ohne cash laden wo ist der disable cash moment der lädt den font
erst wenn ich es an klicke sehe ich das richtig
ipad das ist gut da kann ich eigentlich eine 3km lange liste machen mit mit fonts und erst
wenn du die anklickst wird das ausgewählt ja nur mit dem unterschied dass ich dann keine
vorschau anzeigen kann du hast das import script am ende das ist kein problem guck da
macht hier diesen import aber wirklich geladen wird das ist das erste mal wenn ich es verwende
was cooles ich habe nichts gemacht um das lazy zu loaden aber er macht das einfach ist
fortschritt immer so langsam nee das liegt nicht so sehr am stream wenn man sachen macht
die man sonst nicht macht ist das meistens nicht sonderlich viel schneller ich hab ja
keine ahnung was ich da treibe eigentlich der selektmenü ist wirklich eklig bäh hier
ist der font so alles klar aber mal das ding wieder unten hin was meint der chat eben um
das schöner noch zu machen was jetzt noch die colors und die font buttons jeweilig in
ein eigenes diff dann sieht das mit dem flex auch besser ne font buttons habe ich ja net
font font buttons also ich mach irgendeinen ich mach irgendeinen drop down für die für
die fonts da fällt mir aber noch nichts ein also was mir vorschwebt ist ja folgendes also
wisst ihr wisst ihr was halt wirklich schöner wäre nicht etwa hier irgendwie diesen kram
einfügen so sondern jetzt doppelt klicken können das doppelt anklicken können dann
kann ich mir hier oben nämlich auch das da sparen und dann mache ich es wirklich so dass
das menü wobei das wisst ihr was chat das machen wir jetzt ich probiere das mal ich
probiere das mal schnell kriege ich kriege ich auf die schnelle hin das menü links zu
platzieren so aktuell sind wir fix am unteren bildschirmrand wie soll das dann auf dem
handy gehen auf dem handy bleibt so auf dem desktop geht's links hin also von der idee
hier muss ich jetzt einfach nur sagen lg moment ich sollte es vielleicht noch mal kurz so
sortieren dass es alles zusammen steht so lg left null right null ist richtig
moment wie machen das jetzt kann ich kann ich kann ich so was machen left null
und dann breite 48 oder so
wie mache ich das denn sticky left top muss ich wahrscheinlich machen null bottom null
ach so weil ich hier die höhe drin habe ok ok ok breite 48 ok so würde ich das machen
auf dem desktop das eigentlich ziemlich nice idee so würde ich das machen auf dem desktop
also vielleicht nicht ganz so hässliche mit ein bisschen ramen oder sowas also so auf
dem desktop und unten auf dem auf dem smartphone ok das bedeutet das machen wir jetzt schnell
noch so das bedeutet left null ok lg top null nur nur nur lg so ok das ist noch klein
das ist schöner kann ich ausprobieren so das auch nur bei lg
ist das sinn von dieser seite custom label drucken zu können genau ein minimaler label
editor hat zwei kunde erstens weil ich schon immer mal ein bisschen javascript grafik
zeug machen wollte und zweitens weil ich einen label drucker gekauft habe der mega
beschissene mobile apps hat und ich eigentlich nur eine webseite will und label drauf und
print und fertig noch vielleicht speichern und laden ok wie kriege ich das jetzt hin
also breite 96 sollte jetzt eigentlich nicht gebraucht werden wie also ich brauche ich
muss es jetzt ja eigentlich docken right right zero ha leute bam moment nicht ganz nicht
ganz fast so ganz richtig ist es noch nicht höhe ein drittel so hatten wir es vorher
auch oder ja so hatten wir es vorher auch ah moment ok lg lg ist höhe dann voll zack
guckt mal da huge responsiveness hier poggers aber lg is rounded none und lg ist auch right
none geht das kann man das irgendwie überschreiben ja anscheinend nicht ja schön fasted das
ist nice dass ihr das gefällt das ist cool das gefällt mir richtig gut guck mal jetzt
ist das auch viel besser auf dem desktop zu zu bedienen und so ist es gut zu bedienen
auf mobile so ist gut auf mobile so ist gut auf dem desktop richtig prog g mobile desktop
mobile desktop wir können es dann aber wir können den desktop view kleiner ein bisschen
schöner machen und wisst ihr was wir machen nicht lg wir machen medium obwohl das schon
rüber rüber switch ja ab hier kann es schon rüber switchen wo ist mein canvas eigentlich
hin sagt leute wo ist mein kett wo ist mein canvas hin aber das canvas verschiebt sich
irgendwie ein bisschen ja gut ist auch so breit wie der bildschirm das ist das ist schick
doch das gefällt mir das heißt wir das muss jetzt bloß hier in dieser größe ordentlich
funktionieren und danach switch das rüber auf die auf die ansicht ja gut wir müssen
das canvas noch verschieben dann das muss alles ein bisschen nach rechts rutschen aber
das können wir das können wir das nächste mal machen das ist jetzt hat man auch die
eigens hier richtig schön drin und da müssen wir ein bisschen weniger dann machen aber
nice nice nice exzellent sozusagen das ist wirklich nice so so eine sache sollten wir
jetzt aber noch machen und zwar dass man den camp hier unten wieder ausblenden kann
hier habe ich das genannt open element browser so das heißt wenn ich switche und der offen
ist also if browser menü wenn das gleich menü eintrag ist und das offen ist dann will
ich schließen hoffentlich funs das jetzt ja aber jetzt geht aber nicht mehr auf warum
geht es jetzt nicht mehr auf hä falls achso ja weil es dann hier zutrifft ähm else so
und hier switchte aber ok nice und ich kann auf und zu machen und jetzt zum abschluss
für heute noch eine richtig feifett idee kannst du eigentlich auch die font der svg zum pass
konf was kannst du auch die font der svg zum pass ich habe keine ahnung was du mir mitteilen
möchtest chat verstehe den jemann etikettendrucke obvius ist das so eins eins machen wir jetzt
zum grünen abschluss heute svelte transitions was hat er jetzt hier für schmerzen all ready
included er ist dumm der checkt es nicht dass ich die endung umbenannt habe keg weight so
zum abschluss machen wir jetzt folgendes noch also if if ups if show element browser
also ich kann mal is is open so rum geht immer noch schnell und jetzt sagen wir in paid pass
mal auf jetzt passiert richtig poggers bäm massive ein und aus fäden menü guckt euch
das mal ok das fällt ein bisschen das fällt ein bisschen zu langsam ein und aus muss
man natürlich sein das mal duration 70 millisekunden oder 80 oder so 50 50 reicht wobei 50 so schnell
das fällt kaum auf 100 ja ich brauche noch out kann man eigentlich out und in in einem
machen 195 laut google x das jetzt jebait oder ist das wirklich so oder einfach transition
so oder wie dann braucht man das nicht verstehe das ist nur wenn man extra optionen haben
will 195 das ist doch viel zu lang für so ein menü man 195 das kommt er ja das kommt
er ja ewig vor ein und auch deswegen fühlen sich die ganze material design dinger so lahm
an weil die animation lamas faks sind jetzt verstehe ich auch die design geschichten von
google das ist viel zu lang da wäre ich verrückt bei aber so ist eigentlich ganz cool fly in
ist noch besser ok das war jetzt frei bleib ich gebe dir hätte alter bleib bleib ist das
jetzt irgendwie anders swelt fly transition epsilon ist das von wo der los flight quasi
das ist schick das ist schick das finde ich gut
das ist nice guck mal hier wie es auf wie es rausfährt alter wie der typ der metal of
honor warfighter aus dem boden gesporn ist der fährt aus dem boden raus hier poggers
und es klappt sogar wieder ein guck mal
es ist ziemlich brauchen es ist auch nicht bottom 0 es ist bottom 12 bottom 12 ist es
und es ist bei ist immer bottom 12 auch hier jetzt sind sie vielleicht ein bisschen bisschen
viel eigens auf einmal oder was mein ihr bis sie viel vielleicht
es ist richtig nice wie das hier rausgedingst moment die transition müsste anders sein
die transition müsste hier hier eigentlich von links kommen es ist eigentlich auch nice
ohne ssr ich mache überhaupt kein ssr gerade ich habe jegliches ssr abgeschaltet mir müsste
jetzt irgendwie checken na das ist natürlich blöd meinst du ich soll das gleich von links
einfliegen lassen das sieht blöd aus aber hier sieht würde das gut aussehen im moment
falsch minus 200 wahrscheinlich hier sieht das halt viel cooler aus und von in groß sieht
das von unten gibt es irgendwie die möglichkeit ins welt zu checken swelt media media break
points oder sowas media queries welt oh nee da muss ich selbst nachgucken das ist extra
klasse dafür nee das will ich nicht ich dachte die hat vielleicht was die haben vielleicht
was eingebaut nee das ist pains champ kann ich da nicht irgendwie eine tailwind transition
machen oder sowas wie war das nochmal tailwind transition nee die sind aber nicht so schön
von der animation her da kannst du ja dann bloß sagen hier is in is out da kannst du
glaube einfliegen kannst du kannst du da gar nicht machen da kannst du glaube ich nur
ein ein planten faden so wobei doch du kannst du kannst die du kannst eigentlich die position
animieren irgendwie naja ganz ehrlich ich glaube wir können auch so damit leben check
doch if window inner width größer ja aber ich hätte gerne etwas eingebautes dafür
ja das kann ich machen kann ich machen
wie würde ich denn das jetzt machen gescheit y 0 was ist eigentlich wenn ich beides minus
200 mache aber kommt von oben reingeflogen ok da kommt so schräg das ist doof ein giveaway
ok was soll ich ich give away ich give away subs die muss man aber selbst kaufen quasi
für 5 euro mache ich ein sub giveaway ich glaube ich glaube das ist top so und jetzt
jetzt müsste ich hier quasi irgendwie checken boah nee oder mir nicht keine ahnung fly x
wait a minute moment wie check ich denn jetzt ob ich überhaupt
resize muss ich muss ich dann sowas hier machen und resize hätte es da gut haben giveaway
würde ich würde ich machen aber da müsste ich erstmal mit hetzner wieder was wieder
was an start bringen so ne oder das ergibt keinen sinn was ich da was ich da gerade mache
nee ich hab mit hetzner nichts am start aktuell und jetzt window if window inner width größer
1000 200 oder größer 1000 irgendwie keine ahnung größer 1000 dann ist x gleich minus
200 und fly y gleich null und els boah das ist aber mega abartig das muss anders das
muss anders gehen und ansonsten umgedreht nee 200 so also nee ah moment ich machs ja
auch falsch ich hab ich hab das ja auch noch drin hier fly x fly y so es flyt von unten
und es flyt von links ok funktioniert aber schön ist ja schön ist das nicht programmiert
setz ist desktop ja das ist tatsächlich besser ja
müsste dann eh nicht von dem resize event sein ja aber ich glaube in dem event vom resize
steht nicht die neue größe drinne oder doch gucken wir mal das ist javascript worüber
wir reden da steht nicht die neue da steht nur das target vom window drinne da steht
nicht neue größe drinne das wäre ja auch zu einfach wenn da einfach alte und neue größe
in dem event drinne stehen würde da haben sie javascript designer so gedacht nee das
machen wir nicht overrated shebaited outdated das machen wir so nicht current target window
ja aber window hab ich doch auch so ein legacy feature was sind dann tailwind tailwind break
points standardmäßig für md 768 ok ist es größer 768 so das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren
ja nice funktioniert genau ok wir können wirklich sowas machen ich keine ahnung ist
desktop falls oder was wobei dann ist es ja aber dann ist es ja beim resize check if
desktop ok kann ich nicht einfach sowas machen reicht das reicht das nicht ist da ist das
nicht im prinzip alles was ich brauche im endeffekt weil er das eh immer neu berechnet
bei dem click also einfach hier check if desktop wenn es wenn es desktop ist dann 200 wenn
es nicht desktop ist null und dann hier auch if check desktop wenn es wenn es desktop ist
nein das ist falsch wenn es desktop ist dann null ansonsten 200 und wenn es desktop ist
dann minus 200 und ansonsten null funktioniert das jetzt easy so und jetzt können wirs noch
besser machen jetzt können wir nämlich das machen was presery vorgeschlagen hat das wir
jetzt einfach gucken was was ich result x y und das wir hier jetzt einfach gucken ist
es größer ansonsten dann setzen wir result ah moment moment nee da muss ich ein if machen
da muss ich ein if machen das funktioniert glaube ich nicht anders aber jetzt nee result
so wenn es desktop ist wenn es desktop desktop kram ist dann will ich dass der das y muss
es groß oder klein sein y dass das nee wenn es desktop ist will ich das x minus 200 ist
so rum und ansonsten will ich dass es das y nee wartet mal leute ich bin verwirrt wenn
es kein desktop ist dann soll das 200 sein ne genau weil man das auch bestimmt deutlich
einfacher schreiben kann so und in duration 100 muss ich glaube ich auch noch zurückgeben
sonst wird das nix also und geht das jetzt kann ich jetzt einfach sagen check desktop
nee das muss weg nee ah ach so weil void moment return so java script stellt ok funst
aber das ist das ist kann man das nicht irgendwie einfacher machen ja doch mir könnte es direkt
hier reinschreiben größer 768 gibt es nicht die auswahl über den user agent user agent
wird auch soweit ich weiß mittlerweile gar nicht mehr großartig abhängig zur plattform
übertragen das ist ja auch so dass du firefox und chrome nicht mehr unterscheiden kannst
die senden alle das gleiche das welt breakpoints gibt es doch nicht irgendwelche helper für
oder so ah da kann man das selbst setzen ok ah nee das brauchen wir jetzt nicht also
wenn das wenn das größer ist dann wird das wird das 200 minus 200 ansonsten null und
dann machen wir das ganze einfach noch mal und sagen hier null oder 200 und dann kann
ich diesen ganzen shit löschen und sag einfach return fertig habe ich jetzt richtig gemacht
bam easy so bald werde ich hier richtig zum fulltime frontend full stack def bis sec ops
cloud native on prem serverless expert engineer dann kann ich alles zwar nix richtig aber
alles schon mal gesehen
man sollte es nicht nennen check if desktop oder wir sollten es eher eher nennen keine
ahnung transition params oder sowas ich ich nenne es jetzt check desktop ich mein was
natürlich richtig was natürlich richtig nice wäre ist wenn wir sowas hätten wie
macht man in zwende wo macht man denn ihr helper functions rein wahrscheinlich einfach
direkt in source wenn wir sowas hätten wie helper js und dann leute wir haben noch viertel
stunde zeit ich kann so ein bisschen dummes zeug machen und dann würden wir quasi sowas
wie check if desktop würde man da quasi rein packen und dann diesen part da irgendwie
rein rein hauen und dann würde ich sagen import helper oder so ne helper ach so moment
das muss ich erst exportieren dass es funktioniert oder ich bin da hört man java script zeug
auf wie funktioniert das richtig oder so dann könnten wir hier unser helper zeug
rein schreiben und hier würde ich dann echt nicht nennen check if desktop sondern get
transition params oder sowas und dann einfach nur noch get check if desktop naja so viel
haben wir dadurch jetzt nett gewonnen so viel haben wir dadurch nicht wirklich gekriegt
so viel haben wir da jetzt nicht wirklich durchgewonnen nicht das ne das hat es jetzt
ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich gebracht na gut wie dem auch sei wir haben doch heute schon
einiges hinbekommen also was haben wir denn gemacht die suche geht jetzt endlich schnell
ohne gelege hat eine schöne schöne überplendung entfernen die klammer noch wo da ne das muss
doch da sein oder oder meinst du dahinter ne brauchen beides also wir haben das hier
schnell gemacht wir haben dafür gesorgt dass heck weh wir haben das sachen dass die bilder
die man copy pastet schwarz weiß copy pastet werden wir haben dafür gesorgt dass wir ein
mobile und desktop layout haben was so ein bisschen verbesserungswürdig ist aber eigentlich
schon ganz gut funktioniert ja wir haben das hier virtuell virtualisiert vom scrolling
her dass es nicht leckt wir haben text insert ein bisschen gebaut wobei man das noch verbessern
kann also meine selektor warum ist mein selektor immer hinter hinter dem dem krempel selection
gibt es sowas konvert set index gibt es sowas how to set correct order of notes using set
index ok selection wo sind wir hier selection selection set index 99999999 das die soll immer
oben sein die selection qr code inserten und gucken ob es funktioniert nicht warum mein
set index ist ganz oben das sollte immer oben drüber sein das ist ein back vielleicht muss
er niedriger sein ja man weiß ja nie minus 9000 selection index was macht das string
ne das was anderes chat set set index so vielleicht das besser reinfolge von den ads ja aber wofür
gibt es denn dann set index set index ist just index of a note in its parent child array
ja gut das ist nicht absolut aber ich habe ja nur ein ich habe ja nur einen layer ich
habe ja nur einen layer das müsste also doch eigentlich funktionieren gibt es auch die
top ist das move to top oh nee das muss ich jetzt immer ausführen oder was leute pass
mal auf beste beste idee ihr wollt mich ich wollt ihr wollt mich deabonen wenn ihr das
jetzt gleich seht funktioniert easy funst das kann aber nicht dabei sein das kann das
kann es eigentlich nett sein das ganz eigentlich also das das wieder strebt mir jetzt schon
ja jemand irgendeine andere glorreiche idee gibt es ok es gibt doch bestimmt ein ad event
oder sowas von der stage stage edit oder so on stage converse stage events so edit oder
sowas muss es doch muss es doch bestimmt geben keyboard event desktop mobile oh ich höre
es vor meiner tür alle leute macht vor der tür hört das nicht da will einer rein ja
schicko mann gleich springt gleich fertig schicko ist hartnäckig gibt es kein event für on insert
oder sowas nein nein nein schicko schicko schicko ist ne katze konver event insert ich
hab keine ahnung kannst du die auf einen zweiten layer legen five hat time so machen wir das
layer das war mir jetzt sehr gute idee sehr exquisite exzellente idee keine ahnung temp
konver layer new stage add temp gleich soll ich den kram ordentlich nennen temp add selection
muss man jetzt das oder das zuerst adden das funktioniert nicht umgedreht temp zuerst zeig
mal habt ihr meine habt ihr habt ihr meine kratzen geräusche aufgenommen naja ich hab
das doch im zweiten anlauf relativ gut getroffen oder schicko mann gleich springt gleich fertig
schicko ist hartnäckig doch funktioniert das jetzt hey chat fife header der fife hätte
wieder einfach zweiten layer adden den mann als letztes edit massive selection layer ich
muss das zeug mal irgendwie sinnvoll benennen ja ne wir nennen es nicht always on top layer
wie ist eigentlich die richtige javascript schreibweise ist es ist es always on top layer
oder ist es always on top layer was ist der java der beste javascript best practice leute
ich komm ja aus der c style programmiersprachen welt da ist es sowas hier vielleicht ist es
auch javascript moment moment vielleicht ist es auch mit minus vielleicht ist auch mit
minus kebab case ist es kebab ist vielleicht auch kebab keine kebab case geht nicht in
dem fall get element by id ja das heißt ja nichts nur weil framework interne sachen so
benannt werden bedeutet es ja noch lange nicht dass das empfehlung für alle ist wir sind
in der javascript welt das heißt kebab case ja kebab case kebab wie das gibt steht da
nicht drin da wäre ein beispiel gut für mit einem minus genau das nennt sich kebab case
aber das funktioniert hier anscheinend gar nicht ok js camel case versus snake case was
zum teufel ist snake case ist das da unten ok was was sagt was sagt ist der gover flow
weiß man nicht ok aber chat richtig richtig clevere idee hier mit dem extra layer da braucht
man hier keine extra wurscht mit always on top und so nice finde ich richtig gut gefällt
mir und was mir auch gefällt ist dass wir text adden können das finde ich richtig high
iq funktionen was übrigens noch nicht funktioniert ist bold und so wie willst du eigentlich am
ende deinen canvas zum drucker schicken ich exportiere das canvas als bild und machs in
pdf oder als png png oder pdf muss ich mal gucken ich exportiere das und dann schicke
ich zum drucker cool wäre auch so ein vorgefertiges layout zu haben ne templates können wir nicht
rein machen das ist viel zu viel zu aufwendig ich meine mal seriously was macht man ganz
ehrlich der label design prozess wird realistisch betrachtet so aussehen keine ahnung das ist
ein geiles label keine ahnung dunkler farbe zack qr code so irgendwie so und vielleicht
noch smile oder happy oder so irgendwie so fertig also viel mehr werden die meisten
leute wahrscheinlich nicht machen was ich in zukunft viel eher mal einbauen könnte
noch ist dass man sowas also was ich auf jeden fall einbauen werde ist dass man es speichern
kann speichern und restoren von dem label das auf jeden fall und wisst ihr was man relativ
einfach machen könnte ist das template bar machen also dass ich zum beispiel das hier
und und den text als template markiere dass man das über einen curl aufruf ändern kann
und zum drucker schicken wisst ihr wie ich mein also das dürfte relativ einfach sein
dann bräuchte ich auf dem solver nur noch ein node.js wo ich das im hintergrund austausche
und dann zum drucker.js dass man das hier die zwei sachen quasi als template markiert
dass man dann auch über irgendeinen curl aufruf quasi den text und den qr code switchen
kann das dürfte relativ einfach sein farbauswahl bringt nichts die label drucker sind schwarz
weiß deswegen kannst du beim text deswegen kannst du hier beim text auch nur zwischen
ein paar wenigen farben auswählen achso ja das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute idee was
haltet ihr farbauswahl farbauswahl für das emote eventuell chat ich glaube eventuell
müssen wir doch noch eine toolbar hier oben machen mit farben und sowas und das nicht
und das nicht da drinnen und das nicht hier drinnen machen
na schauen wir mal
ja ja das kommt auf jeden fall noch hin ich mache dann hier so einen rahmen ich mache
einen rahmen mit ein bisschen platz drum herum dass man auch sachen jetzt stellt euch mal
vor dass hier stellt euch mal vor dass hier wäre das etikett ja stellt euch mal vor das
hier wäre das dass das hier wäre das etikett so ich werde es dann so machen dass ich ein
bisschen über den rahmen rausschieben kann weil vielleicht möchte man manchmal sachen
abgeschnitten haben oder so aber sowas werde ich sowas werde ich da noch hin malen ich
mache hier mit gestrichelt rot gestrichelt oder so rot gestrichelt die wirkliche größe
des labels wobei es nicht die wirkliche größe des labels ist sondern so aspect ratio entsprechend
zum zur canvas größe also dass es dann irgendwie so hier ist einfach dass du von der weil beim
drücken wird eh vorher runter skaliert auf 36 mal 89 mm aber ich mir gefällt das auch
das ein und aus fänen finde ich sehr nice ja siehst du leute beim qr code aktuell rückte
einfach in qr code ein der muss ja beim qr code braucht ja noch text also wir brauchen
für ein qr code auch sowas hier man kann mal aufschreiben ja und da könnte man auch
sagen wir können zwischen bar code und qr code auswählen oder sowas also wir könnten
beispielsweise genauso wie hier beim text oder wie hier bei den emotes der demo kann
auch graustufen aber halt gefaked gefakte graustufen der der lässt einfach den hintergrund
weiß und und und drückt daneben schwarz und ja der kann graustufen ja also das wenn man
jetzt hier beispielsweise auf qr code klickt dass dann auch sowas hier aufgeht wo man dann
auswählen kann will ich in qr code will ich in will ich in barcode haben was gibt es
da sonst noch barcode qr code was auch immer alles und dann muss man ja noch den text eingeben
der auf den der auf den barcode drauf sollen welch ein label printer 450 das ist noch
einer ohne dm dot code was ist dot code so was benutzen leute das kenne ich das ist
blindenschrift auf der auf medikamenten packung und sowas das habe ich auch schon gesehen
ja ach nee das ist nicht blindenschrift was anderes das benutzt jemand hier dot dot code
kann man auch alles einbauen wichtig ist erstmal dass wir so die grundlagen haben dass wir
die richtigen edit elemente haben und sowas dann kann man auch ein paar sachen einbauen
wenn es ja muss ja nicht total übertreiben dass es noch nicht auf github aber das kommt
dann auf github wenn es fertig ist oder wenn es wenn es irgendwie halbwegs funktioniert
so wie ich mich kenne wahrscheinlich nie kein quake alles klar leute wir sehen uns im nächsten
stream ich gehe jetzt auf badgit time was läuft eigentlich auf deinem normalen computer
distro windows in der vm in der vm ist manjaro linux mach mal ausrufezeichen linux oder ausrufezeichen
manjaro im chat ist es glaube ich irgendwo habe ich da mal ein bisschen länger was drüber
erzählt wir haben auch einen ganzen stream gemacht wo wir das zusammen eingerichtet haben
muss beim archiv gucken ok leute wir sehen uns bis denn machts gut cu